This is Jocko podcast number one 17 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
And we're doing a Q and a tonight.
First one in a while,
had a bunch of other guests and books and whatnot.
So Q and a.
Let's go.
Cool.
First Question Jocko from one 15 podcast,
number one 15 as a leader,
how best to respond to someone like Corporal Meyer when he brings up good
questions in a brief that need to be addressed without derailing the brief and
calling your com pretense slash authority into question.
Okay,
so what he's talking about is on podcast one 15 with Dakota Meyer,
which if you haven't listened to it,
listen to it,
it's long and it's very,
I dunno,
it's,
it's awesome.
Anyways,
in part of that podcast,
Dakota,
his getting told how they're going to conduct this operation and Dakota raises
some point and says,
what about this?
What about that?
And what about this other thing?
And they don't listen to them.
And so the question here is if you're in charge,
you're the leader and you get someone that brings up these questions during a
brief,
during the plan that you need to be that need to be addressed.
How do you do it?
How do you handle that properly?
Okay,
well first of all,
and the most important part of this is if you involve your team in the planning
itself,
you won't have these questions come up during the brief.
They'll come up during the planning.
So that's,
that's the ultimate and best way to solve this problem.
You don't plan in a vacuum as the leader and then present the plan to the troops
and expect that you're going to have the perfect plan.
It was only your brain working on it.
What about everyone else's brain?
What?
I'm not on everyone else's perspective.
They have experience and they have knowledge that you don't have.
So if you involve them in the planning,
then they ask you those questions early and you figured out what the right
answers to those questions are.
So that's how you solved the problem right there.
Now if it happens that for whatever reason you're,
you didn't have the opportunity to do that or you didn't do it well enough or
whatever the case may be,
and now you start getting questions on your plan while you're briefing.
Well,
first of all,
if they ask you questions that you don't have answers to,
then that,
then that could indicate that you're wrong.
Actually,
you could actually be wrong and not a lot of leaders like to feel that way,
but you should actually be happy that someone on your team is pointing out
something that is gonna make the plan better as a whole.
So there's that and it's really easy if someone,
if you're in a brief and someone brings up a point that you didn't think of and
it makes sense,
well then you can implement that into the plan.
Okay,
so that now you might think that it hurts your authority,
right?
To say,
hey,
that's a good point.
Echo,
I think of that.
Let's implement.
You might think or feel like that's going to make you look bad,
but it's the opposite is actually true.
If I go no echo,
hey,
the plans already completed.
You weren't there for the planning,
so just be quiet.
That's the guy that no one respects.
That's the guy that's not looking good as a leader and that's the person that's
losing authority so you don't look weak.
If you listen to members of the team,
whether they're junior or senior,
it also shows that you're incompetent if you,
because you,
because you missed a part.
Obviously the question is pertinent that they asked or I should say if the
question is pertinent ended as a good point,
then it shows that you missed an important angle of the plan.
So
open your mind,
open your,
put your ego in check and incorporate it in there.
Now this can also happen if there's something that you know that you're right
on,
but something that you know that you're right on.
If there's something like that
and you and this,
but you know,
maybe you get one particular individual that's keeps pushing back and keeps
pushing back and you might have to in those cases say,
you know what?
Hey Echo.
Let me,
let me talk to you after this brief is over and explain to you exactly why we're
doing it this way.
So that way it doesn't derail the brief because it might take a longer
explanation than you want to.
You know,
for instance,
the typical seal briefing was we tried to keep it 50 minutes to an hour.
So if you have got to,
if you've got to spend eight minutes pulling up a different map and explaining
some detail of the terrain to this guy that has a protest to what you're saying,
you might say,
Hey,
listen,
when we get done with this brief,
I'll pull you aside.
Let me show you the,
let me show you the terrain map and you can see exactly why we're using this
insertion route or whatever the case may be.
Uh,
so you can do that if you have to.
And even then they might end up having a point that you didn't see and then you
can say,
okay,
well I didn't see that.
And now we have to give everyone a quick,
quick on a rib reefing on some change in the plan.
But again,
none of this will happen if you bring your subordinates in and you let them do
it.
First of all,
let them do the planning.
That's ideal.
Let them come up with Atlanta.
Let Echo come up with a plan.
I'm not coming up with a plan.
You go come up with a plan.
I'm going to check with you and make sure that the plan is going in the right
direction.
Make sure it's not totally off track and then you'll incorporate all these
things and I'll have a better view of the plan.
I can stand back and be the tactical genius as we talk about in the book.
Extreme ownership.
Like that's how you do it.
So that's the answer.
What have at least an answer.
Yeah.
Maybe other people have other answers.
Seems to make sense to me.
Yeah,
that's that hard.
It's hard,
right?
When you,
when you,
it's one of the things you always gotta be conscious of when you have a plan or
whatever and someone for lack of better term pokes holes in it and be like,
Hey,
what about this?
What about this?
And then you have the that those two elements that you got to keep in mind where
it's like the fact that it's your plan and then the plan,
you know the effectiveness of your emotional attachment
to the plan.
Yeah.
You got to keep the emotional attachment to the plant in Jack versus the actual
effectiveness of the plan and people have a hard time doing that.
And what's cool,
what's cool is once you break away from that mindset and it's really easy just
to be,
and everyone just kind of knows,
Oh yeah,
Jack was here,
he's got an open mind,
he'll listen to you as opposed to someone that has a closed mind ever goes out.
You can't,
you can't get anything by this guy who just,
he's just got to keep,
he doesn't even help to point things out cause he won't listen.
And then guess what?
You're using one brain versus 20 brains and more important than the brainpower,
the perspective,
the different perspectives.
Cause the guys in the ground of the guys with the technical knowledge and the
tactical knowledge,
they're going to know things that you don't know.
That's the way it is.
You can't know everything that they know.
And so if you shut down all those different perspectives,
you're looking at something from one angle and do you see the whole complete
picture when you only look at something from one ankle?
No,
you don't.
No Sir.
Use those other perspectives.
You know,
check self correcting machine.
He's getting let go of the ego,
the taking it personal.
When I was in the seal teams,
I called it the emotional attachment to the plan because I can see these people
come up with plans and they would be so addicted to their own plan only because
it was their own plan,
not for any Knob,
for any tactical or strategic or operational reason whatsoever.
They just liked it cause they thought of it.
It's natural.
It's very natural.
And there's some element of of benefit to that,
right?
Because if you're passionate about your plan and I'm passionate about my plan,
as long as we can eventually come to compromise,
then we've put forth the best idea.
Because I don't want you to not be passionate about your plan while you're
planning it.
I want you to really come up the best plan that you really believe it and,
and it's interesting,
you know you talk about poking holes,
right?
Poking holes in the plan and we all know that it's very easy to sit back and
poke holes in the plan.
And what I'm telling you to do as a leader is to absolutely do that.
Not Be a jerk.
No,
no.
And I'm talking to as a leader,
if I,
if I let you do the planning,
but it's easy for me to sit back and poke holes in the plan,
which is good.
It's good because we're going to come up with,
we're going to fill those holes.
Once I poked the holes,
we're going to fill them and we're going to know that they're taken care of.
Also as a leader from a,
from a perspective point,
you think,
hey Jocko really knows what's going on.
He was able to find these holes in the plan.
The real reason I was able to find them.
It's just cause I was not totally at at minuscule detail with the plan you were,
I was up at altitude,
relaxing,
looking around.
Yeah.
It's kind of,
I don't want to say cheating such heating but it is cheating is cheating is
cheating.
It's that much easier.
It's so much easier to sit back and do it and let things go that way.
Like when you know when you watch a movie and you have like some critique the
movies outstanding and then you have some critique I have,
they shouldn't have chose that guy for that role or whatever.
Meanwhile the movies like groundbreaking,
whatever,
you know,
so it's easy to poke holes the movie.
Meanwhile
like yeah,
yeah.
When it's done you're all like poking holes at the little imperfections.
Do that all the time.
It makes sense.
Dig It.
Does that happen with your videos?
Is that what I'm saying?
Probably Jack.
Anyway,
next question.
We have been training Jujitsu for two months now.
We started actually rolling a few weeks ago from our knees on the mat,
like not starting from standing.
Basically.
I've trained for an executed multiple,
oh,
I've trained for and executed multiple marathons,
competed,
completed a number of tough mudders,
trained hard and crossfit,
hiked,
biked,
swam,
and nothing compares to the total mental and physical exhaustion I feel after
training Jujitsu.
How can I combat this time,
train more supplements.
Just suck it up.
When I get home,
I'm so beat in the next morning I wake up feeling like I was hit by a bus.
I know that feeling right away despite the exhaustion and still sucking at it
for fun.
Okay,
so that's the Jujitsu that's and okay,
so there's a couple of things here.
Yes.
It's going to take some time.
You're gonna have to train you train more.
Your body will become conditioned to it.
That's probably number one.
Number two is,
and this is so hard for people to do.
Relax.
Yeah.
It's really hard,
really hard for people to do,
especially when you first start out.
I realized that the way you get to a point when you start to relax
is when you're,
when,
when the capability of your technique surpasses the capability of your strength.
So if I know that I can escape your choke attempt by holding your hand and
pulling your thumb and pull your arm off.
And that's what I know,
that's what I'm going to do.
And when I realized that I can use a technical escape of swimming my arm in and
then placing my hips on the ground and then scooting away from your choke,
I'll do that instead.
But,
but until we figure out the techniques,
all we have is muscle.
So you,
the way you do is you just have to keep,
keep training and keep training and try.
You can try.
Can people actually,
when they try and relax,
do they actually get you?
You tell me.
Cause I always tell people like,
relax more rob.
Like some will say I just can't relax and I'll be like,
relax harder.
Yeah.
But,
but it's hard.
It's so hard for people to relax because people say,
oh,
and I relax.
I just get submitted.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
So,
but if you relax,
you'll at least be aware of what's happening.
And if you relax,
you can think about the technical,
the technical movement that you're supposed to do to escape.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I feel like,
just like how you
said though,
if you don't know the move,
you're just going to go with what you know and it's gonna be a spazz in one way
or another.
Jay,
you know,
if a guy's on you ever affect it?
Well,
cause I,
cause I'll,
I'll go into,
yes,
yes.
Sometimes I have to spazz and dean calls me out on that a long,
well,
here's the thing about good defense.
You just spasm will but has a big more than a sprinkle of technique in it
though.
That's the thing if true,
like you and I told you this one time,
you know how like if you say,
yeah,
you're strong and that's kind of an insult in Jiujitsu because it's like saying,
you're strong but you don't have tech.
It's kind of like that's what you're implying.
But,
and I said this to you one time,
I was like,
you have like strength,
you're strong.
And you were like,
not defensive,
but you were like,
no,
I have technique or whatever.
And I was like,
yeah,
I know that.
I was like,
shoot,
that sounded bad.
I mean,
you have technique,
we already know that you've been training for 25 million years and you have good
technique.
But with that technique is like a lot of strength in there.
Like when you,
um,
there's like stuff,
oh yeah.
When like if,
if I'll be inside control on,
on top on you and you have this like first off,
your hands are in the correct spot just to begin with.
It has to be,
and you can just kinda get your leg and real easy every single time.
Like,
I can't talk to stock it,
stop it.
And I'm not weak.
I'm not weak.
But it's like the strength of that move is like,
oh,
it's unstoppable.
And that's when I said it and I was like,
you're,
you're like strong when you do a technique.
It's like,
it's a strong technique.
And I would say though there's a lot,
I would say it's probably 70% technique and 30% strength,
which,
which may confirm what you're saying that 30% strength is still more than if
someone has 70% technique.
What they have only 10% strength to get back it up.
Yeah,
fully.
And even saying it's you know,
70% technique,
30% strength,
I mean that's going to vary from time,
from moment to moment or experience sixth street.
So if you're spasm even that's going to be a spectrum.
Like how much strength did you use?
There's this technique kind of thing.
Cause you can't spouse for a long time.
Nope you can,
you'll just be tired of you get to speed gassed.
Yeah.
So when I say you're strong,
here's the thing.
The fact is your strong,
regardless of your technique or not,
you can lift a lot of weights.
You're big trick grab.
Like I'll grab your wrist and when you break the grip of the wrist,
it's way more violent than the typical person.
You're a strong person.
So there's no denying that.
I know it sounds like an insult winner,
but nonetheless back to the point yet.
And so if you,
if you have strength going in before you gain all that technique over the,
over the years,
just like how you said that's what you're going to use it.
So the key is here I think is to consciously,
and it's not easy consciously focused on the technique consciously like
remember,
okay,
where am I?
How many half guard right now?
Because you know how like in the beginning when you first learned that the
positions,
you're like half guard is real clear guard is real clear.
When you start rolling around,
you're halfway upside down.
Maybe twisting,
maybe your arms
in the wrong spot across your buddy or something like that.
You kind of don't remember a week.
I'm in half guard right now or an upside down.
But I mean,
you know,
I'm on his back still,
whatever.
So you don't,
he doesn't just stick in your mind what position you're in.
But if you can do that then it starts getting getting routine.
So now you,
after that you can figure out,
okay,
am I safe here?
Because that's why you spend,
that's why you can't relax because you don't know if you're safe or not.
So you're just trying to move in and get out of there or,
or you know,
get that submission herea before he does something.
You know,
where the supplies to life,
this applies to life in when you're interacting with other people and you start
to,
let's say you and I are having a disagreement about something,
right?
And you start getting the upper hand on me and instead of me trying to use a
technique to get out,
all I do is go the stupid echo.
You're done.
Right?
I just started interrupting or cutting off raising my voice.
I'm actually losing now and I don't,
you know,
but I'm relying on brute force as opposed to technique.
Now it could be also,
like we talked about earlier,
it could be that I'm wrong and if instead of admitting that I'm wrong or,
or taking,
like you're saying,
relax and looking at the technique and saying,
you know what?
Echo has a point here that I can't debate against.
He's right and I'm wrong.
I need to admit that.
Same thing.
If you came up with an idea for the plan and your idea was better than mine,
or you had a point that I needed to bring into the plan,
unless I almost,
I can relax and actually pay attention,
then I'm not gonna be able to do that.
So that's how,
that's one of the many ways when I was talking about Jujitsu,
applying to life.
This is another example of where,
hey,
if the argument starts to escalate and you're using brute force to get out of
it,
you're not winning.
Just like you're not winning in Jujitsu.
It's if you're going to gas out and you're going to,
you're going to lose.
Yeah.
Don't use brute force.
Not even 30% well,
maybe sometimes 30% it's okay.
The other thing is the other thing that's hard and it's,
well,
it's,
it's attached to what you're saying.
Don't have death matches every time.
Yeah.
Right.
Don't like you find a partner and just be like,
okay,
let's try and make sure that we're not using so much strength.
I can roll with you or with dean or with Andy or whoever for a long time and,
and it's,
you know,
we're sweating or tired,
but we're not using all this strength.
You don't walk in off the mat with,
with,
with like burned out muscles.
It's a difference.
More of a cardio I would say then then a strength thing when you get to a higher
level because you're,
you're just movement.
It's movement that's happening.
You know when to,
you know when someone's going to accomplish something and if you're going to
fight it with muscle,
you're gonna,
you're gonna end up losing.
Yeah.
And it goes back to the time thing where I was,
is it more time
in the dancers?
Yeah,
it's more time.
Cause like you,
you learn that.
And again,
like where you knowing where to be and where not to be,
where you're safe in,
where you're not safe in Jujitsu is a big deal.
So you know how like,
okay,
let's say,
and I know this with you because let's say if I pass your guard,
sorry,
you let me pass your card.
I don't know.
You don't spazz and like,
you know,
like in a tournament where the guy's like really trying hard not to let you
settle in guard.
And so that's a different scenario of course.
But you never do that.
You,
it's like you get to a point,
pass your guard.
Once you kind of get there,
you just,
you set on your,
you're kind of relaxing because you,
it seems like anyway that you know you're not in danger for a submission.
So that's kind of really where the focus is.
It's not the fact that,
Ooh,
he passing my guard.
Oh no,
that's terrible.
It's not that.
It's okay now what technique do I need to implement to keep myself safe?
And the more you know about Jujitsu,
the more you realize it doesn't take a huge amount of energy to,
to implement that technique.
It's usually just like an arm position.
Make sure his hip is like over there and not over here.
And that's kind of,
that's it.
That's pretty much it.
But if you don't know that you're like,
oh man,
you're using your whole body to get out of there kind of thing.
And that's,
that's when you're leaving.
No reserves in a military perspective.
In the military,
you're always supposed to keep your reserve as long as you can.
Oh yeah.
You're just trying to spazz out and get out of a dominant position.
It also attacking a dominant position when you're responding to try and get out.
You're,
you're just going crazy trying to get out of this confirmed position.
I mean,
across the side or the mount.
Those are positions that are really sure.
There's a transitional time when you should definitely spazz to try and get out.
Once that's surpassed,
well now you're just,
you're just expanding energy.
Yeah.
So check your diet too.
If you're like really sore and everything,
make sure you're getting enough protein.
Make sure to get enough fat.
Make sure you're getting,
maybe get some,
get some super krill or some or some joint warfare or both because
your body needs it.
So just other things to try and put off that
soreness and the pain.
Yeah.
All right.
Well that twisting.
Yeah,
there's definitely,
you know,
well,
yeah,
it's hard on your joints.
Yeah.
Die Hard.
It's like us not to get a workout,
you know,
they get a workout that you won't be getting doing other stuff unless you know
construction or something,
you know,
something like that.
Same thing.
You're going to get joint stuff.
That's how,
but yeah,
keep it supposed to be fun.
The death matches still death matches.
Yeah.
White Belt death matches probably.
Um,
I would estimate 40% of all injuries in Jujitsu come from white belt death
matches.
Is that you think that's a good number?
Yeah.
If not higher.
Not Higher.
Yeah.
Full on.
Cool.
Next question.
You talk about,
you talk about empathy and perspective and building relationships as a leader,
but I look at leader,
a leader like Steve Jobs who's known for his hostile attitude toward
people.
Isn't that being default aggressive?
Like you talk about,
if I'm more naturally that type of leader,
should I go with it?
If it worked for Steve Jobs,
shouldn't it work for me?
So
that's a good question.
And I haven't actually read the book about Steve Jobs and I think there's
probably more than one,
but there's the one that's real popular,
real thick and someone gave it to me and I have it and I will someday.
But I haven't read it yet.
And I've heard it's really good.
And all that.
And I,
that being said,
I've,
I've heard the same things about,
you know,
Steve Jobs,
that leadership style,
he was real tyrannical.
And I pulled a couple things here just from,
well here we go in his book about jobs time at next and returned to apple the
second coming of Steve Jobs,
Alan Deutschman described job's rough treatment of his underlings.
He would praise is a quote,
he would praise and inspire them often in very creative ways,
but he would also resort too intimidating,
goading berating,
belittling,
belittling and even nick humiliating them.
So,
and there's another article by Ronald Riggio who's a phd in psychology and the,
and the article came from psychology today and it says he was obsessive,
we controlling and given to fits of rage,
throwing tantrums and yelling at employees and board members.
He could tear down someone's ideas or the person himself in a public display,
some of said he took credit for others ideas and his confidence led to a sort of
over the top arrogance.
So the guys kind of tyrannical one time when they were putting together the
mobile application and it wasn't working well and jobs told the team that was
putting it together to give when it wasn't working,
you've tarnished Apple's reputation.
You should hate each other for having let each other down.
So,
okay,
so first of all,
let's look at the factory.
You've heard me say this before,
that people's strengths are their weaknesses and their weaknesses can be their
strengths.
So in Steve Job's case,
obviously some of this stuff,
some of his weaknesses that we're talking about here,
we're also a strength because he was totally beyond driven,
right?
He was completely obsessed with,
with doing good and all that.
And,
and he pressed toward his vision extremely hard.
He was relentless in trying to make things happen.
And again,
those are very positive characteristics.
If you've got someone that's really driven,
they're driven to the point of almost being obsessed.
And you,
you take that and those are kind of good characteristics,
but when they go too far,
this is why it's dichotomy.
This is the balance of leadership,
right?
When when you go too far,
you become a tyrannical leader,
which is not good.
It's not good for a team.
And it's,
and a team that is subjected to that of attitude will not perform as well as a
unified team,
period.
Period.
So the guy was clearly hostile and at the same time,
clear,
clearly he was one of the most successful business leaders in history,
right?
So
would you look at them and say,
okay,
well maybe I should be that way.
Maybe I should be a tyrannical leader.
And I would say to that,
no,
you do not get to do that.
And here's why.
Let's look at some other characteristics that Steve jobs had.
First of all,
he was perhaps the four most technological visionary in the history of the
world.
I mean,
he had a vision of technology that very few people in the history and the world
of hat and I will go a little bit more narrow.
I think he understood things on a note,
another level when it came to technology that the part of how human beings would
interact with technology.
That's the part that I think he really had just incredible vision for.
He realized like,
Oh,
these people will want a computer in their house and they'll want it to reflect
the way they live and they're going to want music in their pocket.
They're going to want all of their music in their pocket and they're going to
want a phone that can do,
you know,
he had this vision of how people would interact with technology that I don't
think too many people have.
So,
so that's number one.
Number two,
he had a phenomenal feel for design,
right?
For Design and how to merge form and function together in,
in an in an ass,
theoretically pleasing and,
and oftentimes stunning way,
right?
If you look at the design,
and that's uncommon,
especially for someone to have that field for design and still have a massively
technical background,
right?
So,
so that again,
we're poor.
We're,
we're making a person that's like 1% of 1% of 1% already on top of that,
he got into business his business at the right time in the right place.
He had the right background on top of that.
The guy could speak well.
The guy was very articulate,
right?
He was very articulate with this vision.
If you,
if you watch his keynote speeches that he would give at the whatever it is,
when they have the apple convention,
what's that thing called?
The apple convinced they have that thing.
Well he'd get up on stage and he'd talk about stuff and he would articulate that
and he would do it with real clarity and he was very convincing and he was very
captivating and people were,
you know,
they'd say Apple's a cult,
eh,
they'd follow that guy.
So he had all those skills,
those world class skills and I'm not using that term lightly.
I'm talking world class skills.
And then they're,
all those world class skills are together into one package,
one human being.
And there you got,
you got Steve Jobs.
So he's got all those advantages.
And then on top of that,
he's had some luck along the way,
right?
You had some luck in his timing and his upbringing and,
and the exposures that he got and being exposed to computer programming and
those things back in the day was rare and he got lucky and having that unfold
form.
So we had all these things going for him that helped propel him and his company
to the top.
So now if you're thinking maybe you should use his leadership style,
the,
the questions that you should ask yourself is,
are you all one in a billion vit,
technological visionary,
a visionary of any kind?
The answer to that is likely know.
And if you think it's yes,
maybe you should check your ego a little bit,
then you have to ask yourself,
do you have an eye for design,
an artistic eye for design?
Like,
like Da Vinci or Michelangelo?
If you have that,
you,
you probably don't.
If you think you have that,
maybe you should check your ego again.
Are you a gifted speaker and storyteller and can you convey your vision with
total clarity to big giant groups,
broad groups of people?
And if you think you can do that,
again,
you should check your ego.
Can you count on luck or do you want to count on luck to,
to close the gaps in some of those other areas.
So if you could do all those things,
if you answered yes a hundred percent to all those questions,
then okay,
maybe you can get away with being a kind of leader that Steve jobs was.
But if you're a normal person,
if you're a normal human being,
then maybe you should try and be a good leader
and maybe you should be a leader that builds relationships in forms,
cohesive teams and coalitions that help you drive your mission forward despite
the ups and downs of whatever business you're in.
So
that's it.
Steve Jobs had a lot of other things that made him successful.
Yeah.
And leadership and,
and he,
I'm going to eventually read the book,
but he clearly had some people around him that,
that utilized that skill.
The skills that he did had it have and move,
help move them forward.
Right.
Other people at the company,
other people early in in apple saw that,
hey,
you know what,
this guy,
he might be a little bit hard to deal with,
but he's got some things that we won't find anywhere else,
so let's prop him up and let's move forward.
And that's the way it works.
I think they call that survivorship bias where you're like,
you see,
oh,
you see a successful guy and he,
oh
yeah,
he did it that way,
so let's do it that way.
Um,
but yeah,
you,
you kind of don't see all the other factors or whatever.
Almost like you,
if you really think about it,
if Steve jobs were to be like in these tyrannical ways of what if he were to be
less like that,
maybe there would be more successful,
you see what I'm saying?
But he was so strong in these other areas that it Kinda like mitigated the
effects.
You know,
there's,
there's businesses that are successful because they're a successful business
model and in the,
he have really bad leadership.
Yeah.
And even that count,
there's still even the bad leadership,
doesn't it?
It's the,
the,
the model is so good.
Yeah.
Which is a little bit contrary because,
you know,
I would say leadership's the most important thing on the battlefield.
But in the business world,
if you have a phenomenal idea,
then you can,
you can be successful on that idea alone.
Now that is,
that is a unicorn.
That is one of those rare things where you have something that's,
that incredibly different and stands out from the crowd so much that it's going
to be successful no matter what.
And you know,
when the,
uh,
when the early gyms,
MMA type gyms,
if you had one,
you are successful.
It didn't matter what kind of leader you are because you had,
you had it and now there's competition.
And if you're not,
if you don't have good leadership and you're not putting forth a good product
amongst all the competitors,
you're gonna have problems.
You're going to have problems with it.
Yeah.
And the more I kind of listened to you in life,
the more I realized that even then the like,
it's almost like you have to have a minimum level of leadership.
Like you don't be,
you have to be perfect if you have the one of these situations where the product
of the business model is so good,
but still,
even your leadership can mess that.
Oh yeah,
you can.
Absolutely.
Because yeah,
like you're in a situation where he'd be like,
[inaudible] no one wants to work for you.
Now what?
Oh yeah,
good,
nice.
Mma Gym.
You don't have any,
you got to work there the whole time and you can't,
you know,
so it's going to kind of fall apart after a while.
So maybe like in the beginning it'd be good,
but it will fall apart because of your,
of,
for sure.
And you can see that,
I mean,
who's the guy that just got removed from Uber?
I'd have to go into,
I'd have to really drill down on it,
but the CEO of Uber got removed and you know,
the business model's awesome.
Yeah.
And they still remove the CEO.
Why?
Because there's,
there's issues there,
eh,
and so,
well it's a great business model but we still need good leadership.
Yeah.
So yeah,
like,
like I'm,
I'm basically confirming what you just said,
the good business model,
we'll get you to a certain level,
but then to get to the next level you're going to need leadership.
And that's why leadership is the most important thing on the battlefield,
man.
So what the moral,
don't necessarily be tie radical.
No,
in fact,
don't be straight up to radical.
Don't be,
and I'm not saying that there's not times where you have to have a little
tyrannical flair cause there,
there may be times where you need to,
where you need to flare up a little bit,
but it should be rare.
Yeah.
It should be rare.
The problem is it becomes a crutch for people and then they just continue to do
it more and more and more and more.
And then it doesn't work.
It's like,
it's Kinda like drugs to the like when you like when you flare up on someone
and,
and you win or whatever,
you know,
you of like it worked.
Yeah,
it worked.
And you kind of lay,
it feels good.
It feels powerful.
Hmm.
So I think some people,
that's how you know,
so they'll do it in an a work and there'll be like,
yeah,
I will need that little,
and what's even worse is when you win,
that's where you,
you learn from someone,
that's what you saw and then the you do it and you go off and work for me too.
And all I have to be is treat people bad and be a jerk and yell.
And the,
my subordinates will do what I tell them to do and they will write a subordinate
will,
if you bark at him and scream at them,
they're going to do what you say at the moment.
The problem is what kind of team of the belt.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
What does that subordinate going to do when you're not there?
You're going to do everything they can to cut corners and,
and really they don't care about,
they don't care about you.
They don't know want to do good job for you.
And so when you're not there,
they're not going to do a good job for you.
So you get addicted to yelling and screaming,
but it doesn't work in the broad sense of what you're trying to make happen
slowly falling apart.
That's the question.
I'm 26 years old.
I'm currently an undercover detective.
I've recently been told that I'm being promoted to sergeant over our
departments,
investigations division.
I've been the youngest person to hold that position in our department's history.
All the guys I'll be in charge in of our much older,
some in their late forties.
How do I as a younger leader lead them?
How do you demand and earn respect from an older group?
I'm ready for the job and know what the job entails,
but I'm nervous to lead a group of nine people that are all older than me.
So,
um,
I've answered this question over and over again and I'm going to do a quick job
of it here just because people may not have gone back and listened to all the
other podcasts,
but you have listened to,
the answer's always the same.
And it's always the same whether you're a young person leading old person,
whether you're an old person leading young per people,
whether you're a woman leading men,
a men leading man,
leading women,
whether you're coming in from a different department into a new department that
you don't know anybody,
whether you're going into a thing that you don't have experience,
it's like all the same.
Basically what it is,
you're going into a leadership position.
That's what it is.
Be Humble.
Listen,
take advice,
build relationships,
keep your ego in check.
Also,
the one of the reasons I pulled the,
did pull this question I was,
he's like,
how do you demand respect will?
The answer is you don't demand respect.
And if you don't,
if you do demand respect,
you'll get anything but respect from people.
So,
so get that out of your head.
You earn respect.
And how do you earn respect?
You respect them.
In this case,
you respect their experience,
you respect their knowledge,
you respect it,
they've been doing it for a long time.
You have respect for it,
and when you show respect for them,
they're going to respect you back.
Now,
none of this means be passive,
right?
This doesn't mean cower down.
No,
you still have to lead.
You still have to step up.
But it does mean be humble,
be open minded,
be proactive,
listen,
ask questions,
ask for opinions,
decentralize all aspects of operations including the planning,
which we already talked about.
And then with all of those things,
set a high standard and then the final and most important,
well,
I dunno,
it's equally important.
I'd say
work harder than everyone else and expect nothing in return.
That's it.
You're the boss.
You better be,
you better be at work before everyone and you better be leaving work after
everyone.
And that's how you develop a reputation of being a hard worker and being a hard
worker in its own right garners respect from most people.
There's,
there's a a fraction of losers that are like,
oh echo,
he works so much.
It's so lame.
Like no,
like cause I'm making them look bad or something like that.
Yeah he is.
He's just,
he's,
yeah,
there's a small fraction of people that that might think that way but,
but no,
you work hard.
You put in the time,
you put in the effort you study,
you read,
which you're supposed to read.
You get the professional knowledge that you're supposed to get.
You don't impose that on people but you have it cause your,
your book knowledge when you start off in this situation,
your book knowledge isn't as strong as the experience guides in this case.
You know in the,
in the law enforcement,
the guys that have been in the streets,
they know stuff that you don't know.
Yeah.
So you study what you can but you keep an open mind so you can listen to what
their experience says.
Yeah.
Like I don't impose on them.
When you say don't impose it on them,
does that mean don't impose them?
Like make them dress them echo.
Section four two alpha of the documents says that we're supposed to use this
methodology.
When we do this,
you should know that methodology.
You should understand why that methodology is important,
but if you say,
Hey Jocko,
we don't do it that way and here's why I shouldn't be locked up.
I'm telling you it's by the book.
Buy The book now if it's by the book because it's,
there's an ethical reason.
Okay,
well that makes sense,
but if it's by the book,
because that's what the book says by the mock.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or you know the guy who's like,
who works extra hard,
but he kind of in a way throws it in everyone's face.
How hard you going to be that guy?
That's,
that's an important thing.
It's a very important piece.
Don't you?
Don't step on people's toes with this stuff that's wrong.
Don't do that.
Check.
It's squish.
Jocko,
I'm extremely,
extremely driven and have high expectations for myself and my team.
It appears that now I may have pushed them too hard
and they're developing negative attitudes.
I feel like you're going to say play the game and develop relationships with
them,
but should are really just ignore who I am.
Should I try to be someone different than myself?
Yeah.
Well you called it question person.
Whoever asked this question,
you called it I,
that's exactly what I'm going to say.
I'm going to say you need to play the game.
Look at what your current path has done.
Look at what you,
the real you,
look what it's done and real you has,
has created a negative attitude with all your team.
That's the real you.
So is that what you want to perpetuate?
Creating negative attitudes against your,
with your team.
And by the way,
they're just getting started and if you think negative,
if you think you're going to keep acting the same way in the negative,
attitudes are going to somehow miraculously turned positive.
That's not happening.
They're going to get more negative.
Yeah.
So
when people have negative attitudes,
and I saw somebody quoted this the other day on,
on social media,
on Twitter,
someone would,
you know the quote was like,
no,
it's not my fault.
When Nice,
my subordinates have a bad attitude or something like that,
and about a bunch of people responded like you should read the book extreme
ownership because it absolutely is your fault.
It is your fault.
If your team has a bad attitude,
it's your fault.
You're the leader.
You own the attitude.
If their attitude is bad,
then it's,
then it's actually your fault.
Now,
this is not to say that you can't have a bad apple on the team.
That's completely possible.
And who's responsible for getting rid of the bad apples?
You are.
You're the boss because the fact of the matter is you might have a bad apple on
your team.
You might even have two bad apples on your team.
You don't have 14 bad apples on the team.
When you have 14 battles,
the apples on the team,
guess who the problem is?
It's you.
So here's what you do.
A little,
little tactical advice.
Try and get some perspective from them,
trying to understand where they're coming from,
what challenges they face,
what's pulling them off track.
And when you do this,
you kind of take ownership of it in your approach.
So you said,
hey guys,
I,
I realize I don't think I'm really seeing things from your point of view and I
need to because I'm here to support you and without you performing well,
then we fail.
So I think I need to do a better job of supporting you.
And I can only do that if I know what your issues are.
So I can do my best to get them fixed.
So what can I do better to help you?
All right?
So now they're going to start telling you all,
here's why.
Here's one.
There's this problem,
there's that problem.
And then what you do is you listen to their problems.
You're actually listened to problems.
You don't say,
Ooh,
group complaining.
No,
you actually listened to their problems and then you actually see what you can
do to mitigate their issues.
And as you do that,
guess what's happening?
You're actually forming a bond.
You're actually forming into a team because you're working together to solve
issues.
Again,
I,
it sounds really simple,
right?
But clearly,
here's someone asking this question.
Now again,
like if you have some members of the team that are,
that are actual negative,
complaining whiners,
then you might have to get rid of him.
And,
and that's part of being a leader is knowing when you have to get rid of
someone.
You,
you know,
sometimes people,
they take the extreme ownership attitude and they say,
you know what,
I'm the leader.
I own everything.
I'm extreme ownership.
And if someone's not performing well,
then that's my fault.
That's my fault.
I need to coach them or I need to,
I need to do,
it's my fault that my team member is not doing well.
And that's correct.
It is your fault.
It's your responsibility to train them,
coach them,
mentor them,
and do whatever else you can do to fix them.
But at the end of the day,
if they still are not competent at their task and you've done everything you
can,
it's your responsible to get rid of them.
That is also a part of ownership.
So
yeah,
like I'll have someone complaining that they've got all this,
you know,
one of my team leaders,
like they're talking about their subordinate teen leaders and the Luma warm I
this,
this guy's,
he's just a bad leader.
Why is he still here?
They owe your team.
That team isn't doing well because they have a bad leader.
Who's fault is that?
If the leader's fault?
No,
it's your fault.
You're in charge of the leader is the ridiculous.
So back to the original question,
you're a,
whatever you called it,
your who you actually are is not working well,
he probably is thinking he's a Steve jobs type a Tacoma.
We've got to do this,
but it's not working and he's not in a unicorn business model that's still
making a ton of money regardless.
So what does he have to do?
Play the game and build the relationships,
see the perspective of your team so that you can actually form a team.
Would you be a better leader?
That's basically what I'm saying.
Yeah.
So the,
in the,
it's interesting the,
what they call framing,
you know,
you frame something,
something in a certain way to make it kind of sound a certain way,
whatever.
So he said extremely driven and have high expectations for myself and my team,
it appears that now I may have pushed them too hard and they're developing
negative attitudes.
So having extreme,
being extremely driven and having high expectations doesn't equal equal driving
him too hard.
So they develop that negative outlook.
Those are two different,
you know,
you can still be extreme.
So yeah,
you can absolutely have extremely high expectations and you can be driving
extremely hard
and you can still have incredibly positive attitude with your team.
Yeah,
no doubt.
good point.
It's so,
and then it gets equated into that's just who I am.
So the,
he just kind of put it all into one ball and without one,
there's no other kind of situation.
It's just not how it is.
So apparently you might be committed,
he might be committed to being all of these things and that's who I am and
that's kind of it,
you know,
kind of thing.
And I think that's like the mistake plenty of people make,
we say this a lot where people will be like,
Hey,
I'm just straight forward,
you know,
take me take it or leave it kind of thing and be like,
okay,
but you're going to in your case lose,
you know,
in your,
in your situation.
That's the big piece is that in their case they're going to lose.
Yeah.
So let me ask you this question.
If you're so driven and you have such high expectations that you want to win so
bad,
but the way you're performing as a human being and as a leader is going to make
you lose,
then what are you supposed to do?
You change the way you behave,
change.
You'd be a better leader.
Yeah.
That's what you do.
Yes sir.
So you take,
and this is total speculation on my part,
but you keep kids.
So this equation that we're presented with x being extremely driven,
keep that high expectations,
keep that pushing your team hard and keep that,
I would say to harden,
that's going to be a judgment call from day to day for sure.
Um,
but there's a part in here that's more implied that you're being an asshole
somewhere in here.
You're being an asshole.
How about do you take out that part?
Take out the bean,
the asshole part,
and then keep everything else.
We'll see how that goes.
Yeah.
Cause you kind of know when you're being a dick.
You know what I'm saying?
Unless you're like not being honest with yourself there.
There's some people that don't,
there's some still don't get it.
There's some people that don't get it all right because it's like,
you know how like when you don't,
like some people they just can't step outside of themselves and be like,
Hey,
if you said that to me,
I wouldn't care kind of thing and be like,
Bro,
Bruh,
you know,
you're not me and I'm not.
You kind of.
Yeah,
you're right.
They kept attach.
Yes.
Absolutely.
People that,
that don't know,
they're socially
incapable of receiving clues,
social clues,
people,
social cues from people,
you know,
they don't see the look in their face when they are talking to him.
Yeah,
that's true.
I mean,
I'm thinking of like three examples for sure.
Yeah.
Also that then that would go back to what you're saying,
how you said get input from them.
So you gotta kind of,
yeah,
so you,
you can do it,
but it's a solvable problem.
So he was a very solvable problem and I've seen people solve this problem.
I've,
I've helped people solve this exact problem.
And the weird thing is they think,
and it's part of ego,
but it's also park there,
just the 1% they think they're doing a great thing.
Like they think that they're driving everything that they're doing in their
mind.
They're just awesome for being super pushing so hard.
It's just the way I am and all that stuff and they think it's awesome.
But again,
if you want to win so bad,
then you have to play the game.
You won't win by abusing people.
You won't win with a team anyways.
You won't.
It won't happen.
Yeah.
It's no use being the best dancer.
If you're not invited on the dance floor,
one of them.
I'll leave that one with you.
Yay.
All right,
cool.
Next question.
Actually that problem is so solvable that you could,
this is possible where you could just show just that much.
Um,
like more,
I don't know,
caring or respect.
Just that much respect and due for like two weeks.
Yeah.
Just the idea that just the fact that you're doing it now,
people would be like,
hey wait,
he's showing a little bit.
Here's this thing.
Here's the thing.
If a person has an ego,
which this person could very well have a big ego because that's why they have
these high expectations and that's why they are so driven because they just the,
if they have that kind of ego,
that's the person that you can't help.
Because if they just look at the team and say,
those guys should be harder workers.
Yeah.
Those guys aren't working as hard as me.
They're not as focused as I am.
They don't care as much as I do.
So,
so everyone else on the team has a problem.
Yeah.
But I'm perfect and you can't,
you,
you know,
look at how driven I am looking at how focused I am,
look at how high my expectations are of myself.
But if,
if you can,
here's another thing.
If your team cannot relate to your expectations,
like they don't even,
they don't even see him as realistic or achievable or anything,
we'll go what could or your expectations.
Yeah.
Well good.
Are they,
they're not any good.
No good.
They don't make any sense.
That's true.
Next question.
Dear Jocko,
I've been watching some of your youtube links with great interests.
Must be a subscriber to the youtube channel
videos.
I'm sure you're extremely busy,
but I have a question.
Yeah.
Which if you have time,
I would greatly appreciate your reply.
I've taken light opening by the way.
Very much so.
Can I,
let me incorporate that approach as well.
I've taken up Bjj,
Jujitsu recently in London,
in the UK,
so a,
so a beginner.
I know you're a great advocate of the system,
but my basic question is,
your opinion,
does it truly relate to real life fight situations?
I'm a man now approaching my mid forties in pretty good shape and I'm looking to
focus on a martial art that would help me if I ever need to defend myself or my
family.
I love the discipline and humility of Bjj and as a workout,
I know,
and I know the philosophy of Bjj is that most fights end up on the ground and
it's here that Bjj
excels.
But what of the other guys or what of the other guys who might be standing
around ready to battle bottle you or kick you in the head once you're grappling
on the ground,
et cetera.
Again,
this is a question that,
first of all,
I mentioned this a lot of times.
Sure.
About,
I'll answer one more time.
Uh,
do you just use the best place to start?
You should also learn boxing,
wrestling and kickboxing.
This is all in discipline equals freedom field manual.
So if you get that book,
He,
this'll be laid out for you.
Very well.
Does so,
so yes,
that's what you should start studying with this guy.
Mid Forties.
Needs,
wants to learn something.
Yes.
Start with Jujitsu.
Does it relate to relate real life situations?
Yes,
it does.
It absolutely does.
I've been in them.
It's extremely effective and you can see that over and over again.
Speaking of Youtube,
you can see how effective Jujitsu is in real fights.
Now
it's important to remember that for self defense,
the grappling arts in general should be used primarily to get away it to avoid
going to the ground.
Right?
Like when you bring up,
oh well what if there's other people that might be there?
You should.
Why are you on the ground Jujitsu?
We'll give you the best opportunity to get up off the ground.
That's what it gives you.
And then you can get away from the people that are getting ready to stick you
with a bottle smashed bottle or getting ready to kick you in the head.
If you don't know Jujitsu,
guess what you're doing.
You're on the ground and you're getting kicked in the head and you're getting
stabbed with a bottle.
Yeah.
That's why you train Jujitsu so you can get up off the ground,
not so you can take someone to the ground.
Because by the way,
and I've said this before,
if your goal is to punch me and you're standing at a punching distance or
striking distance from me,
I can just run away.
That's my self defense.
I can get away from you.
So that's why we train Jujitsu.
That that's the primary.
That's why you should start with it because otherwise I'm just going to get away
from you if you're not grat.
If once you grabbed me though,
I can't get away from you anymore.
Now I have to be able to to handle myself.
That's why I know you did too.
So I can handle myself once you've grabbed me.
If you're not grabbing me,
I can just get away from it cause it run away from you.
If you don't want to run away because it's going to hurt your pride.
Well then guess what?
That's that's why you train all the time.
I mean now,
now we go back and forth and we can talk about all the negative things that will
happen if you get into a street fight,
like the fact that you can get hurt,
you can get stabbed,
you can get shot and you can get sued,
you can get arrested,
you can ruin your life,
you can do all these horrible things can happen if you get in a street fight.
So,
so,
so that's why my advice to you is to avoid street fights.
Yeah.
That's what you do.
And by the way,
that's why you work on your awareness.
That's why you make your,
your,
your wife and your children aware of what's going on around them to pay
attention to what's happening in the street.
It's one thing that was interesting when I was in Australia and I was in a nice
part of Australia.
There's Alice talking to some people about it,
you know,
there's just a very relaxed atmosphere where I was,
I was standing in a very nice part of Australia.
There's a very relaxed atmosphere where when you're in America,
there is a heightened atmosphere,
does a heightened awareness you have to have.
And depending on where you are,
and it's the same thing I'm sure in Australia,
I don't know,
I'll do,
went to the nice part.
I'm sure you could go to some,
some tough areas where you better be more aware of what's happening but teach
your kids because some kids don't know the difference.
Maybe you don't even know the difference of what to look out for.
What kind of people you need to watch out for in the street.
So work on that and then yes,
train.
And you're in the UK and,
and of course I've said this before,
if you are truly in a situation where you feel threatened on a regular basis,
well then what you need is a firearm.
Because if someone's going to attack you with a knife or with a bottle or with
themselves having a gun,
the only Jujitsu isn't gonna help you.
Boxing is going to help you as scream was not going to help you if someone has a
gun.
So yeah.
And,
and by the way,
oh yeah.
If you're in a knife fight and you know,
some,
a scream of that will help you,
but what if the other guy's better than you?
What?
What if there's two of them?
Yeah.
The minute you put two people against one,
the odds of winning are just extremely low,
extremely low.
Does it happen?
Yes,
it happens.
Can you knock someone out?
Yes,
you can.
That's why he trained boxing.
Yeah.
So
yes,
again,
trained some Jujitsu,
start there and go and keep going.
And don't stop.
Yeah.
It seems like this question always comes from a place where they just assume all
these things and those things are,
I'm going to choose to get in a fight with someone,
bring it to the ground in the middle of the street or in the club on and
wherever,
wherever there is potential other attackers with bottles and kicks to the head.
And so all of these things are just assumed.
Kind of like,
yeah,
you take Jujitsu now you can go to the club and get in fights.
And when all the time,
it's kind of like,
that's kind of where the question's coming from,
where,
how you said,
yeah,
it allows you to get up and it's,
so basically it allows you to control your situation,
your fight scenario more.
Yes,
and I would even say it allows you a lot more to control it because even if even
if you do take it,
let's say you take it to the ground,
I meant more by a little bit more than nothing.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
I'm seeing a lot more because really when you think of it in a,
and I try to granted,
yeah.
Even like at a beginner level,
so let's say,
okay,
if you choose to engage with somebody in some kind of fight,
right.
It's up to you how heavy you want to take that fight.
You want to go to 10,
you go to 10,
you want to go to just one,
you can go to one.
So if
you wind up on the ground,
which is the worst place to be if you didn't know anything on the ground.
Yeah.
And that's a site from how you said if the guy has a gun and shoots you,
that's the day you're talking about.
That's not even a fight scenario.
That's,
you know,
um,
so you wind up in the ground.
It's a gunfight.
Gunflint yeah.
Um,
if you know boxing,
you're going to have almost no control over that scenario for we're in the top.
You're boxing is,
you're,
boxing is not worthless.
Marginalized.
We'll say it's,
but it's a heavily marginalized.
Yeah.
Heavily marginalized.
Same thing with,
you know,
kickboxing and whatever.
So
there's that.
If you know Jujitsu,
just a little bit of Jujitsu.
If you're on the ground,
you have control over the fight more depending on your level,
whatever.
So if you,
if you're at that point,
still facing the threat of someone with a bottle or kicks to the head or
whatever while you're on the ground compared to if you know Jujitsu versus if
you don't know,
did you get to,
you're still saving way more controlled way more so meanwhile,
like the box situation or credit situation,
whenever it's going to going to be less effective in controlling your situation.
Now if you don't look at it like that,
like if you look at it like,
okay,
this guy's squaring up to me now,
I want to mess him up as quickly as I can,
then okay,
you know,
like you can do boxing and just take it to 10 but you don't have the option of
taking it from one to three or nothing like that.
But the other thing is like,
it's hard to knock someone out that's,
it's hard to knock someone out.
Does it happen?
Yeah,
it does happen and it can happen to you too.
It can happen to you too.
It's,
but it's hard to knock someone out and it's,
it's risky.
As soon as you start saying,
okay,
you and I are going to just trade punches,
there's a risk for both of us as a risk for me,
the assurance of me being able to handle the situation the way I want it to go
by closing the distance with you,
getting control,
getting ahold of you.
If I'm trained and you're not,
you're,
you're done.
You're done.
Right.
That's the way it works.
Yeah.
And then even then that's like if you choose for this guy to be done,
so if your,
if your sole purpose is to keep yourself safe,
yeah.
You could just put the guy to sleep and walk away.
Yeah.
Gently lay down like mount,
I'm not even hurt.
I'm not going to put them to sleep.
Nothing mount.
You see a guy,
you can see the guy coming with a bottle or whatever.
Way More.
If you know Jujitsu well,
there's the whole thing of when you're just used to the physical contact to
the bodies clashing and grappling less shocking.
Yeah.
So yeah,
train Jujitsu and trained boxing,
wrestling and kickboxing and then of course now people will be like,
what about judo?
Yes.
Trained judo.
What about Samo?
Yes.
Trane.
Samba.
Yeah.
What else?
What else do I need to?
Cool.
What about Krav Maga?
Sure.
It's train it.
Train everything.
Yeah,
I'm down at star.
Would you do to what you said on a real general level is the most critical thing
is like when someone gets a hold of you like,
and you put this into perspective a while ago when you were like,
yeah,
if someone wants a fight you walk away or run away,
easy to buy it.
And he said all of these scenarios,
you run away and you go away.
You want to keep yourself safe.
You don't be there.
Best thing to do to avoid the,
the getting punched,
falling on the curb,
dying,
getting stabbed,
getting kicked,
getting stabbed with a bottle,
getting arrested,
getting lawsuit,
getting all those things happening.
The best thing to do.
Runaway walkaway.
Yeah.
Leaf fully.
And then you said,
but what happens when you can't run away?
Because this guy grabs their,
there you have it.
Yeah.
So yeah,
so it seems like,
yeah,
I'm going to train boxing so I can do self defense.
No,
you want to fight somebody.
That's what you want to do.
You want to punch people in the face it,
well you did too.
I mean,
yeah,
but boxing is a,
is a skill that every buddy should have.
Not everyone.
Good people should have because there's two critical things on that that you
learned from boxing.
How to punch people in,
how to avoid getting punched and how to keep your guard up right.
Fully.
Those are important.
Those are really important skills to have.
Yeah.
Fully.
But what,
what I mean is if you're starting from nothing and you're like,
okay,
I'm going to,
um,
you know,
I'm going to choose to address my self defense.
You tuition,
you have a fantasy that you saw a guy on youtube that was clearly a boxer,
knock a knock out,
two people in a street fight.
And you're like,
that's what I'm going to do.
Yeah.
That's what you actually watched was a guy that was a golden gloves boxer who is
sober,
knock out two drunk idiots.
And guess what a golden gloves boxer will do that.
If you ever sparred with a golden gloves boxer,
they're freaking good.
They're freaking good.
They're,
they're,
they're uh,
you know,
like a black belt in boxing and they will knock out two drunk guys all day long.
Yeah.
It's weird too because he kind of hut if one of those,
if a third drunk I or even that first drunk guy grabs a hold of the boxer yeah.
And just,
and gets him to the ground,
the boxer is going to be in trouble.
That's the way it is.
And this isn't my thoughts.
This is facts.
Cause like I talked about this in discipline in the field manual is like,
look,
there's no conjecture.
It's not like I wonder what would happen.
No,
we know what happens.
We know what happens when two people fight and,
and you can watch all the different,
various types of styles going at it.
And you can watch what happens and sure,
you can find the rare video where,
hey,
this boxer knocks out a couple of drunk people or,
or,
or even,
hey,
the boxer knocks out the digital guy.
Does that happen?
Yes,
it can absolutely happen.
That's why you train boxing.
Do you next question.
I have not been working out regularly,
regularly for several years now.
Obviously I'm fat and lazy,
but I want to get after it.
So the question is should I go all in
level nine,
destruction,
maximum madness or ease into it at level three cruising.
All right,
well this,
there's a couple of different approaches and then when I hear this,
first of all,
you don't want to get hurt,
right?
And you also don't want to make yourself try and do things that are so hard and
so painful that you can't do it repeatedly.
Yeah.
So if you just destroy yourself,
Matt,
what do you say?
If you destroy yourself?
Level nine destruction,
maximum madness,
but then you can't work out for two more weeks.
Well guess what?
What'd you do in the mean?
No,
let's say realistically you got Dom's comes.
Sure.
Right.
Delayed onset muscle soreness.
Let's say you did so many burpees that your legs,
you couldn't sit down without your legs being in pain.
So now,
so you take,
so you take three days,
four days.
Have you ever had dom so bad that you took four days off?
No.
Okay.
Let's say you take three days off.
What did you do during those three days?
Did you hold the line?
Did you stay on the path or were you eating Cheetos?
Yeah,
you're wrestling colon.
That's what you are doing.
So if you destroy yourself to where you can't stay on the path,
that's not good.
You want to stay on the path.
I think doing something that you can handle or maybe something just beyond what
you can handle every single day is more important.
So going at a level,
not,
not cruising level,
not level three,
but let's,
let's find a solid level five where you can,
you're pushing yourself.
I write a thousand words a day when I'm writing and let you do the equivalent of
that.
Right?
The reason I read,
cause if I said,
okay,
I'll do it tonight.
I just today I just have to write 5,000 words.
That's five hours.
You know,
we'll do I have five hours today.
No I don't.
I can squeeze out 52 minutes though and get a thousand words written that I can
do.
So that's,
that's what I think you need to do.
You need to get consistent.
If you bite off more than you chew than you can chew your,
you might very well choke on it.
So Don,
so don't do that.
And so pick something realistic.
Do,
do people say that?
That must be a same first time I heard it.
So if you bite off more than you can chew,
you might choke on it.
Did you make that up or you get that from somewhere?
I think I,
well I just,
I don't know.
I think I made it up,
but I'm sure someone will be like,
no,
this guy said it in 1978
that is the beauty of it.
Good.
So pick something realistic,
like for something that you can handle and then get after it.
Then the other thing here is he doesn't talk about his diet at all.
And that's clearly equally important and you have to change
your diet if you're going to change your life and you're going to change your
health.
So stop eating sugar,
stop eating processed foods,
no more soda and juices and no more Gatorade
just to start with or whatever it is,
whatever it is that you're doing.
Uh,
whoever asked this question,
whatever,
you know what you're doing.
If you're eating donuts and don't,
don't eat donuts anymore,
stop.
Just stop eating those.
Get rid of that sugar,
sweetness craving thing.
Yeah.
And then just keep making your diet cleaner and cleaner as time goes by.
So
that's what I think.
Is there any time that it's good because sometimes
I think it's good when people do go like,
all right man,
I'm done.
Like I,
whatever happened,
they went up the staircase and they,
they,
they got all tired and they said,
you know what?
I'm done.
Yeah,
it starts tomorrow.
But I think in those cases,
most of the time,
who was it?
Who was it that we were talking to?
Talking to someone,
someone that they are,
I was talking to someone that their first thing they tried to do,
they couldn't do at all.
Like they tried to run three miles and they were like,
you know what?
Can't do it can't run three miles.
Oh it might've been that guy.
There's a guy that's losing a bunch of weight on the interwebs.
Oh yeah,
that's what it is.
I think he's down in Texas,
but he's trying to lose a lot of weight and you first time he went and tried to
go for run didn't happen.
It didn't happen.
So he had to just run less or had to just walk actually.
So yeah,
you,
you start with what you can do but there is a little bit of,
there is,
I would try,
I would say this,
keep this one in the,
in the back of your mind there is the whole thing of like,
you know what,
I'm changing my life right now.
You go home,
you get the garbage can out,
you bring it into the kitchen and you throw away the Twinkies.
You throw away the pop tarts,
you throw away the,
the,
you pour the crappy soda down the drain and you get on the path and you just
don't look back.
That's a good thing to do too.
But again,
if that person's 300 pounds,
they're not going to be able to do,
I mean,
they're going to push themselves.
Yeah.
They could push themselves too hard.
You just gotta be careful.
Yeah.
So,
and that,
it's funny when I'm,
when I'm kind of looking at the question,
I'm like,
well obviously you want to start slow,
right?
Obviously.
But then I don't tell you hear about these guys,
just like how you said they'd just,
they throw everything away.
They were like,
I'm a new different person.
Right.
And I think,
I think we're,
we're,
we're crossing streams here or I am,
there's diet and then there's like a workout.
Yeah.
Because Diet,
you can pretty much go cold Turkey today.
Yeah.
It limits and you may or may not be able to relate to this,
but if you go straight extreme on your diet,
like all of a sudden you're hit with these,
the byproducts of changing your diet,
especially if you,
if you'd like,
like mountain dew every single day and you just,
all of a sudden boom,
stopped drinking month,
you'll go through stuff that you might not expect.
Like the craving wait,
you saw are free and minimal doses of mountain.
No.
Yeah.
Basically I'm going to say no to stop.
He stopped drinking mountain dew.
You don't need it.
And I dig and you're going to go through withdrawals,
right?
You go through caffeine withdrawals and sugar withdrawals.
You're going to get the,
the,
the Kido flu and all those things are gonna happen and it's going to be rough.
But yeah,
but they'll just say it like that is going to be rough.
But that's all it,
bro.
Seriously.
If you go into that and you experience these types of things and it's gonna
apply to everything,
by the way,
any big change that you make where you,
you have to deprive yourself of these bad things that you've become kind of
addicted to or whatever,
you're going to go through all kinds of changes.
And that goes for workout too,
by the way,
because like just the soreness alone.
Oh Dang.
I wasn't expecting the soreness.
Oh,
I'm like tired now because the workout like was kind of hard.
It's like,
Oh shit,
I wasn't expecting that.
I was expecting to feel great after my workout,
how everyone says or whatever.
So you're going to run into all these little things that no one tells you about
and then it's like,
well,
I didn't sign up for that little part of it.
And then wherever that little part,
and then you're going to have the diet thing.
I think you're wrong.
I think the Diet thing,
I think if you're,
I think it's very,
I think it's easier in fact to just be like,
I'm done.
It's not like,
okay,
you know what?
I'm only going to eat a quarter bag of Cheetos a day from now on.
I don't think that works.
I think you've gotta be like,
no,
no Cheetos,
Cheetos in my house.
But I do think that you could work out so hard that you're so sore that you,
that you say,
Oh man,
I'm just to like kind of like the Jujitsu question earlier on.
Like you could be,
what if someone's so sore that they can't do their job right and they're just
sore all day at work?
Well that's not cool.
So I think for Diet you can,
you can go cold Turkey or actually called steak or hot steak.
And then I think for working out is the one you,
you,
you figure out what you can do and you push a little bit harder,
but you don't go level nine,
maximum destruction madness.
I think you're wrong respectfully.
And which part do you think I'm wrong on the Diet?
I think if you go extreme with your diet,
I think that it'll work for some people for sure.
But depending on who you are.
But I think you're more,
if you go extreme of the Diet,
you don't like slowly phase out the west.
You know what's,
you know what's interesting?
I don't know if you remember,
I read a letter a while back on the podcast about a guy that had red way of the
warrior kid and he fixed his life.
Him and that guy did what you're saying.
He just made little changes.
He made little changes along the way.
So maybe it's personal.
It's probably personality.
In fact,
let's just go ahead and say it's personality.
Some people are gonna just have to get the damn Cheetos out of their house.
All of them.
Yeah.
And some people will say,
you know what?
I'm only going to have this one cup full of Cheetos every day.
Yeah.
And Eat.
And that's okay,
but,
but here's where you gotta be careful.
You may lie to yourself
and you can lie to yourself.
Hey,
you can lie to yourself and be like,
ah,
know,
I don't really that,
that,
that big of a deal today.
If I just have two cups of Cheetos and today.
Yeah.
Nine cubs.
The Cheetos later Cheeto Gfsi and respectfully.
I don't like your Cheetos example.
Why?
Because you're like,
I'm going to allow myself to eat.
Okay.
Don't allow yourself to those.
That's not how small of a change you're going to make.
If you're not gonna eat Cheetos anymore,
you're not going to eat Cheetos anymore.
I'm saying like if you go extreme on the your diet,
let's say you eat,
when you say what you're saying is,
hey,
I'm going to change my diet.
Okay.
I used to eat every day.
I'd eat a whole bag of Cheetos and now I'm only gonna eat one cup of Cheetos
from the bag a day.
That's improvement.
It is improving its small improvement and if I could do that,
then why?
Why is that not okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
If you choose to do that,
but okay,
now we're going into the specifics of a certain person's thing.
I would say this,
this is more along lines of what I'm thinking as far as specific examples.
If you're going to go,
if I'm going to eat one bag of Cheetos,
obviously that's not all I'm eating.
I'm eating other stuff.
I'm,
the small change is I'm not gonna eat Cheetos anymore.
I'm going to cut out Cheetos.
That's it.
I'm still not eating that good.
You know,
I'm cut out Cheetos or let's say a,
I get um,
you know,
drive through every day,
three times a day.
Okay.
I won't get drive through anymore or all.
That's a big change.
Not necessarily,
depending on what you get going from three drive through a day,
two to zero.
The how's that?
Not a big chair.
That's a big challenge is going from like,
and there are certain people,
actually I was talking to someone the other day that had lost 150 pounds a
female and it was interesting,
her nutritionist,
she hired a nutritionist and the nutritionist said,
okay,
what are the foods you can't live without?
And we'll work around those.
That's a pretty cool thing.
And what she said was,
I need cheeseburgers and fries.
So then what she got told was something along the lines of,
okay,
you can have cheese burger and fries on Friday.
Yeah,
yeah.
Instead of,
you know,
this,
this whole thing of I can never read it.
Now what I'm saying is there are people,
and I think I'm one of these people where it's like,
Oh,
if I have cheeseburgers and fries today,
well then I might as well just get a mint chocolate chip milkshake with it.
And if I did that tonight,
then you know what,
tomorrow morning,
Hey,
after you get done training,
maybe if you know that cheeseburger was good yesterday,
how cloud.
So maybe it's my own personal weakness,
but for me,
I,
I'd prefer to be just like on the path.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's why the 80 20 rule,
and I talked about this in the field manual,
the 80 20 role,
maybe it works for some people and I guess it does work for me,
but I'd rather just be straight on the program.
You know what I mean?
And,
and then,
and you know what Tim Ferriss has that thing where,
or he's talked about the thing where he goes six days hardcore strict and then
the seventh day you literally eat whatever you want as much as you can.
And I tried that I have and it's really,
really good because you feel really,
really good.
Not only physically but just about the whole deal.
I'm on the program and you kind of know and on that,
on that cheat day you do,
they call it the cheat day,
you eat whatever you want and you don't feel any guilt at all.
Even when you're on the 80 20 it's like you have to be coming off a real strong
weak to be,
to feel good about three hours are good too.
Yeah.
And that's what's even really that bad of a cheat day.
Cheat Day is like fries.
Then you're starting to go into it for sure.
But
like,
you know,
a cheat day,
cheat day,
like ask Tam Hilt.
It'll be like for real,
like a whole thing of donuts.
Redox,
a cook.
Yeah,
whatever you want.
Straight up whatever you want.
Here's the thing though,
with when you,
when you start to eat healthy and then you try to eat a whole box of donuts,
you after like one,
two,
three,
maybe six,
eight donuts,
you going to be like
in six donuts,
easy.
Six donuts in one second.
Gosh,
you know those,
I think they're called intimate old fashion.
They're like,
you know what I mean?
They'll give me the little chocolate dawn.
That's no,
you know what?
I'm to full size donut,
great out there.
Kind of a little bit bigger too,
you know?
Okay.
You know,
I can't even fathom eating six donuts I ever since I started talking smack about
donuts.
Yeah,
I know.
I can't literally can never have one again in my life.
Yeah,
no,
you're not allowing for sure a hundred percent a hundred percent not even.
Yeah.
Even bite.
Even if you are like,
if someone was like,
Hey,
just is this out?
When I was a little kid and my parents would buy the chocolate dawn,
that's the hosts is chocolate covered in chocolate and those things are good.
Yeah.
You can't even have one of those again.
Nope,
because I did the six day cheap program.
No,
even then you can't,
I can't do it.
You know the old fashioned donut is right.
It's like a doughnut with a hole in it right now.
It's called old fashioned donuts.
They're like,
it's their kind of glazed and almost like a,
not,
they're not crispy,
but they're kind of hard or hard on on the outside and then their regular soft
on,
it's on the inside and they have this glaze over.
Okay.
So I think it's,
I forget the name,
I think it might be intimate,
but they have old fashioned donuts where they're not as hard,
but they're kind of hard and they're just bigger.
Anyway.
Those were my favorite ones.
And Ac get chocolate milk and heat up the chocolate milk.
It's like hot chocolate and donuts and all.
Yeah,
easy money.
Like I'll eat two boxes of those for sure.
Or I used to anymore.
Oh yeah.
So not the point there is on a cheat day you just go,
yeah,
no shame.
But after,
the thing is you can't just eat doughnuts four times a day or three times.
You just don't feel good like your stomach gets all upset in.
The more healthy you eat,
the more it's going to be like that.
So the longer you're on the path,
you start like if you ate some donut,
like the other day we went to the Belmont Park and I ate some ice cream,
some mint chocolate chip ice screener.
Was it good?
Fine.
It was good.
But you know,
all the kids are doing whatever's tracks the the night.
Yeah.
You eat a big large double.
You know what?
After,
after that you're like,
Bro,
I don't feel right.
You know,
so unless you're just committed to eat it,
cause I don't know,
you don't want to waste it or something like that,
you're going to be like,
aw,
my cheat.
Your cheat day is not going to be that bad.
This is what I'm saying.
Oh,
okay.
But I'm still do have that freedom making it happen.
It depends on what it is.
Yeah.
You could pump some Chili fries or something.
I don't like Chili fries.
All right.
So yeah,
maybe what's the verdict then?
I think just in the middle of the road nut,
the whole starting life balance.
So you're saying balanced as well.
I'll tell you though,
man,
if that balance doesn't work for you,
you're going to have to step it up.
You're gonna have to go hardcore.
I'd give yourself two weeks,
two weeks for a balanced approach on the diet side.
If you can't get your shit under control in two weeks,
you got to go hardcore.
You've got to get in there with the garbage clinic can throw away the Twinkies,
throw away everything else that's crap and your fridge and go hardcore and start
with a fast too,
a fast as awesome a fast.
I don't even know that there's that much to expect.
The only for a day if you never done it before,
it's not that big of a deal.
There's no little stuff.
Don't eat your day.
There's little,
there's not take you from a normal human being.
This little stuff,
they,
if you're not,
if you go in and not prepared for it,
then you're like,
oh,
actually no.
Actually I think the more you think about it,
prepare for it.
The more psychologically order it is just to be like,
oh yeah,
you know what?
I woke up this morning.
I haven't had eaten the last night call.
I'm not going to eat until tonight.
Every time that's
when I'm like,
I'm not going to until this.
Then I go through little stuff,
but if I just have,
if I'm too into work,
I don't only drinking coffee and I forget.
I'm like Dang,
if if I eat and I haven't ate for like 12 hours,
then I'll be like,
oh I'll just go another three.
That's my 15 cause it's like 15 right.
15 hours is when your body starts to kind of shift over to like I think 15 what
I read is core,
so I'll just wait that shower.
It's like cool.
Done.
But if a planet,
that's when,
yeah,
I dunno,
but it depends on who you are man.
But that's a good,
I agree with the fingers off.
Yeah.
That's a good way to kick things off and get like jump onto the path.
His jump on with a fast.
Yep.
Hey,
go see your doctor or whatever.
If you go see a doctor to fast 24 hours,
I think you should if you've been
a fat lazy,
you know,
especially if you're older or something like that.
I think CIENA talks get a personal trainer.
Depends on what you mean.
Helmet and I just talked to,
she's like personal trainer and nutritionist hired them.
Both lost a hundred pounds.
So yeah,
I think she was an excess of 300 pounds.
Yeah.
And when I met her,
she's completely normal.
Right.
Like you know completely like you wouldn't even suspect that she had any weight
trouble in her life.
That's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
So hire the trainer,
hire the,
the,
the nutritionist.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think that helps.
I always looked at it like why would I hire like a trainer or something like
that when I can kind of look up that stuff.
But here's the thing,
I went in with this bias like,
cause it kind of had a background in it.
So I'm like why would it,
I can just go look and,
but I'm looking it up,
but I have all this other knowledge.
The same rule.
You've try it for two weeks,
see if you can keep yourself on the path and if you can't got to bring someone
in.
Right.
Here's what I like.
Hire a trainer but not like every day.
It's like a once a week trainer who can get you on a little program and that's,
you know,
it's going to depend on who you are straight up,
you know who can keep you on.
Yeah.
I mean that's the biggest part of all this and I've said this a billion times,
like you know what you need to do.
Yeah.
You know what you need to do.
You know?
If you can't get yourself to do it,
maybe you need to give someone to help you do it.
Yeah.
The weird thing is like nutritionists and stuff,
you can get nutritionist that could come to you and be like,
okay,
we're going to go put you on a low fat diet.
You know,
which would be really not good seeing you in the wrong direction.
I don't know how many of you think there's still nutritionists that are doing
that right now.
There are,
I know there are actually,
there are some,
there are out there so you've gotta be careful that
check
next west.
Last thing that,
I'm not going to draw it out,
but you said you know what you need to do and one time you said imagine what
your day would look like.
Like if you,
like everything you did
was you did the things that you knew you were supposed to do it kind of thing.
Well the,
the,
the full,
the full statement is if you wrote down tonight what you were supposed to do
tomorrow,
you know,
and then you did the things that you were supposed to imagine how that day would
feel and imagine what you'd get done in that day.
Yeah.
And then imagine if you did that everyday for a week and imagine if you did that
everyday for a month and they did it for a year and imagine where your life
would be.
Your life would be in a completely different trajectory.
Complete.
Completely different.
Yeah.
And that's true with working out.
That's true with nutrition.
That's true with business.
That's true with education.
That truth knowledge.
True with everything and everything to kind of know what we're supposed to do.
Yeah.
Oh,
I thought you were going to say some people don't know what to do.
I'm not,
could be the case.
Some people they've never worked out before,
and if you're a person that's never worked out before,
you probably need to bring someone into the game that's going to help show you
how to work out.
If you've never done any reading about eating and you have no idea what's going
to be good for you,
you're probably a person that might need to bring someone into the game to help
you get over that.
Yeah,
and it's still completely goes with exactly what you said.
It's like you know what to do and even to help that you know what not to do.
Like when you're,
you're about to make decision,
I'm gonna do this or not do this.
Like you know which one is you should or shouldn't do.
So let's say I don't know anything about working out,
but I know I have to get in shape.
We all know and you know,
we all know when we got to get in shape,
so then you know you're going to hire somebody,
you know you've got to do something.
You know that you might even just be like,
oh well I'm not going to do it.
I don't know.
I'm not going to do it.
Things to do tomorrow in a trainer,
join a gym,
get a trainer.
Yeah,
I don't know what to do.
Okay,
this is what you can do.
Find out what to do.
There you go.
Then in that case,
so you got to make sense.
Sometimes when you put things in,
just say stuff,
just put it on the table.
Just starts to make sense.
Next question.
I'm a veteran of the infantry and when I took over a fire team for the first
time,
I made the mistake of drawing hard lines in the sand.
This immediately alienated members of that team that had been together for some
time.
I did not make that mistake again and I definitely learned from my experience,
so clearly there's not a question there.
Yeah,
and
I forget pulling this out from,
I get a lot of emails and messages and all that,
but I thought it was a good point to bring up to say,
you know,
this idea of drawing hard lines in the sand and what that does to your
leadership position.
It's,
it's a,
it's a difficult,
it's usually not a good thing to do if you draw a lot hard lines in the sand and
eventually you realize that they're either unrealistic or people can't maintain
them,
you have set yourself up for failure.
What does that exactly like us,
no matter what,
we will not Gotcha.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
There's the Lug,
no matter what we will,
we will win every single road march that we do as a fire team in this while
we're,
while we're here on this training thing.
Hmm,
okay,
well guess what?
That's a,
that's hard.
There's other,
there's some other fire teams that are also wanting to win and and so you've
drawn a hard line to send.
That's not really a good example.
A good example.
It's like,
no matter what,
we're going to muster every morning at four 30 in the morning no matter what.
And you know,
then the guys are out on patrol until two 38 in the morning and now the next
morning you're good.
No matter what I said,
no matter what,
it's not good for them.
It's unrealistic.
So you drew a hard line in the sand and now you've got to back it down.
So,
and all you have to do is soften the statement a little bit.
Hey guys,
to the best of our ability,
if we can,
we're going to get here every morning at four 30 from Oster.
There's a little,
there's a little room to play there.
Right.
And that's,
that's fine.
So again,
I,
there's,
there's not a lot of,
there's not a question here,
but one of the reasons I think that,
that I,
that I wanted to talk
about it was because I think people look at me.
Yeah.
And even hear me on a peripheral level and they think,
oh,
I bet jack would just lay down the hard lines.
Sure.
Yeah.
It's my way or the highway.
Right?
Yeah.
And,
and the,
the,
the opposite is actually true.
And the reason that I came to that conclusion was because I worked for leaders
like that and I hated working for leaders like that.
So I tried to never be a leader like that.
Hmm.
And there's a dichotomy,
right?
She was a huge dichotomy because this doesn't mean that you're not driving and
pushing,
this doesn't mean that you're not saying,
hey,
we're going to be the best,
whatever.
Would it be the best task unit here?
It doesn't mean you're not saying,
hey,
look,
we're not going to rest until we've done what we're supposed to do.
Doesn't mean that.
Hmm.
What man,
you got to find that balance.
Yeah.
It does feel like that with you.
You're like,
it feels like that,
but when you were one,
I mean,
my experience obviously is we're an under no,
like extreme circumstances,
but just like,
just like the simple stuff,
like it really does seem like you wake up at four 30 in the morning every single
morning,
do or die when the percent I did that.
I do,
uh,
unless like there's sometimes where I get home at,
like I remember a little while ago I got home at one o'clock or two o'clock in
the morning and that's basically my cutoff zone.
If I'm getting less than four and a half hours of sleep,
then I'll be like,
oh yeah,
I'll wake up.
And I've been like,
Hey,
I only got two and a half hours of sleep last night.
That's not enough.
I'm going back to bed.
Right.
That's the end.
That's what I mean where I've tweeted that out before.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I get,
yeah,
that's,
that's what I mean.
Yeah.
So it's like when,
when that happens,
it almost like he catches you off guard,
you know,
when you,
when you did that,
I mean,
obviously not like,
oh,
drill cools daughters strict.
It's not that feeling at all.
It's just kind of like,
Oh Dang.
You do have that flexibility when you know,
when it's the correct thing kinda thing.
Yeah.
You have to,
yeah.
You're not a slave to your,
uh,
rigidity.
Well,
what you're saying is I don't draw hard lines in the sand.
Yes,
exactly right.
But it's real easy to go down the slippery slope of like,
wow,
you know,
I actually didn't eat real good yesterday,
so I probably need some more sleep and recovery day.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
Well I am.
I'm,
it's a rest day,
so I might as well turn on the TV.
Oh,
well it'd be good with TVS.
Maybe some popcorn.
Oh,
you know,
it'd be good with the popcorn.
Maybe some cheese sticks until payment apps.
It's the rest day,
right?
Yeah.
He went down that slippery wrong pass.
That's what I'm saying.
I guess the,
I guess the opposite of the of the,
of the path is the slippery slope.
Exactly.
Right.
Next question.
Hi Scenario.
It's actually legit way to think of it too.
Yeah.
If it's a legit way to think of things.
If you're on the path when you know what the Path is,
as we talked about with Tim Ferris,
if you're on the path,
which you know well,
when you step off the path,
it's a slippery slope.
Meal off the path is a slippery,
slippery slope.
And then what'd you just say?
The popcorn can lead to cheat sticks,
can lead to Bam and dams.
That's the slippery slope right there.
And sometimes he slipped so hard that you just plunge deep
off the path,
fall off the wagon.
Land hard
scenario.
My team leaders boss came to me and asked my opinion on my horrible team leader.
Okay,
awesome.
My boss's boss,
one of my opinion.
So what do I do?
Praise him to make the team look good and maintained my relationship with my,
with the team leader or tactfully tell the truth and build the relationship with
the boss with,
that's a good question,
isn't it?
This is a,
that's a really tough position to be in.
Yeah.
Because you have to be careful and you have to be balanced.
And there's a couple of things to think about.
First of all,
no one likes rats.
Yeah,
right.
No one likes rats,
but at the same time you kind of also have to think about what's best for the
team on top of,
and kind of the opposite of no one likes rats is no one likes Brown nosers.
No.
But at the same time you have to build relationships up and down the chain of
command.
And one of the toughest things about this and what you have to be so careful
about is that you don't know what kind of relationship the boss and the team
leader have.
You don't know for a one end of the spectrum they can be friends.
So if you say something bad about them that's going right back to the team
leader and you're in your,
you're going to have a hard time,
much worse position.
Yeah.
Also they could be enemies and supporting the team lead to the boss could
actually make you look stupid.
Right.
Making make you look bad.
And,
and it's important to say here,
is it the optics of like I don't want to look bad.
Is that what I'm talking about?
Cause that's what I just said.
Like it'll make you look bad or make you look stupid.
The reason that you're trying to look good is because you want to do a good job
because you want the team,
cause you want the mission to succeed.
That that's what's important.
And you don't care.
I don't care if I have to eat crow,
I don't care if so.
So I don't mind looking bad if it's for a good reason.
I don't mind my ego taking a dig if it's for the right reason.
But this could actually hurt the way I do my job because now my boss,
my boss,
sorry,
my boss's boss thinks I'm kind of an idiot.
It's,
that means when promote comes time for promotion,
even though I might be the best guy,
I'm not getting promoted because I was the guy that was too blind to see that my
team leader was an idiot.
Yeah.
So I would be very careful and fairly neutral
in what I said,
especially to start with.
Right.
So you know,
if the,
if the boss says,
hey,
how's that team leader do it?
My responsibility,
how do you know we get the job done?
That's so noncommittal.
Right.
Well what about the team leader?
Is He,
is he a good leader?
I think he's,
I think he's got a pretty good hold of what's going on.
Right.
So that's,
that's there's room to interpret that in any direction really.
Yeah,
I think he's got a pretty good hold.
All right.
I think he's getting a hold of what's going on.
Or Oh,
another one would be,
well,
hey,
how's your team leader?
I think our performance kind of shows where we're at,
right?
So you're not,
you're not giving away.
And those are those that,
like I said,
those are subtle and those are very open things that you could respond to.
And,
and I think the more your boss robes or the of the Mo,
the teen boss team leaders,
bosses probes,
the more you can open up a little bit still with caution.
But as you see what the boss's opinion is,
you could open up a little bit more and share a little bit more of the truth
very tactfully.
Or if,
or you could go in the other direction.
Right?
If you said,
oh,
you don't,
that's my best guy.
And I've known bill forever.
Yeah.
Bills.
I brought him here at bill's going to be,
he's going places.
So are you going to derail that guy?
You,
you can,
but you're probably gonna derail yourself too,
because that guy has a bludge intimate relationship with them.
So
that's a tough situation.
And,
and I would say the best thing to do in this situation is remain as neutral as
possible.
And again,
you know what,
there's,
there's someone that's listening to this right now.
Let's go,
oh,
jock was kind of a jock who's kind of a wimp.
If I was there,
I just tell the truth.
Okay,
so let's,
let's talk about that.
Let's talk about what happens.
Cause I've been in that situation more times than I can count where my boss was
kind of an idiot and I get asked by his boss,
hey,
how's this guy doing?
So let's say you rat them out.
Well,
does that mean that the boss gets fired immediately?
No.
It just means that your team is less respected.
It means that you get less support.
It means,
and if you do get ratted out,
by the way,
where do you end up now?
You end up in a bad situation where the,
your boss knows that you ratted him out to his boss.
You're hated.
Yeah,
you're hated.
So I wanna win.
Let's go back to that point.
I want to win.
So does it help me win if I rat out my boss or if I rat out my team leader to
boss?
Does it help me when
it could?
It could.
If your boss happens to be completely aligned with what you're thinking,
he also happens to have a replacement ready that's more squared away.
That's another thing.
You get rid of one bad team leader.
Now you get a new team leader.
How do you know him?
Who's that?
Who is that person?
Where'd they come from?
The devils.
What does that saying?
The devil you know is better than the devil that you don't know.
So if I have a team leader that's not doing a good job,
who's fault is that?
Right?
Yeah.
I can help my team leader,
especially if my team leaders week,
I can help them become strong.
I can help teach them tactfully not stepping on their toes.
I would rather rather than rap my team leader out up the chain of command,
I would rather fix my team leader.
I would rather help my team leader become better support them.
And by the way,
when you do support your team leader and they become better and now they do come
up for a promotion,
what do they know in the back of their mind?
They know that you helped him.
They knew that.
Know that you got them there.
Guess who's getting promoted now you are now.
Why am I so concerned about getting promoted?
Just cause I wanna want to outdo everyone else.
No,
that's not why?
Because you want to win.
Cause I want to win.
I want the team to win.
And if I thought that you echo would do a better job if you became team leader
instead of me,
I'd be like,
Hey,
I appreciate it.
But Echo would do a better job than me.
He should be the team leader.
So
and,
and also if you re this is what happens if I'm really a person,
this is,
this is this,
this is what I'm getting at.
If I'm really a person that really wants to get promoted and that's my main
goal,
I want to get promoted,
that's my goal.
What do I do with the team leader out?
I throw him under the bus.
So that's the person that we all hate.
The person that rats out,
the team leader that that says,
oh,
that guy's doing a terrible job.
I'd do much better job and gets that guy fired and now I get promoted.
What do we all think of them?
We all think that guy's a turd now,
as opposed to someone that says,
you know what?
Our team leaders week needs help,
needs support.
I'm going to help them.
I'm going to support him.
I'm going to do the best I can.
Wait,
are you saying to tell the boss this,
to have that attitude like I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna to throw him under the bus.
Now if we have a guy that's horrible,
that's tyrannical,
that does a horrible job,
that abuses people,
then we get to a situation where you say,
you know what boss?
There are some problems.
Yeah,
so if you have that one,
which doesn't really where this guy says horrible team leader.
So if this is a horrible team leader that's irredeemable,
irredeemable qualities and it's negatively affecting the team cause he kind of
makes it sound like make the team look good.
So there's,
there's,
there's still a possibility that the team is doing okay even though they have a
horrible eater cause they are such good troops.
I would see that sometimes they'll platoon has a bad leader but there's great
guys in there and the platoon leader is smart enough just to like,
okay I'm going to let them kind of run with it and they'll be successful.
Yeah.
So my,
my goal usually is to help the person above me in the chest wall.
It's always to help the person above me at the chain of command.
Can you get to a situation where someone is so bad that it's negatively
effecting the whole team and you can't win because their position?
Yes.
Well then you need to step up and do something about it and say something about
it.
Do it tactfully.
Do it slowly.
Don't overcommit to your statements early on because if you do,
you might say something that is out aligned.
So that's,
it's a tricky situation.
There's no definitive answer,
but you have to weigh these things out.
Generally,
if you can help someone win,
you're gonna win.
Generally,
if you help someone when you're going to win,
if it's so bad that they're just bringing down the whole team and you cannot win
with them in that position,
you might need to say something.
Yeah.
Especially if everyone on the team kind of feels the same way.
It's going to be a little bit easier to be like,
hey,
you know,
yeah.
And be straightly.
Yeah.
But even if everyone was w we,
we,
if we have the gang mentality,
right?
Like,
hey man,
the boss sucks.
You know what?
He's team leaders.
Horrible.
He doesn't know what he's doing.
Hey guys,
you know what?
We could sit here and complain about it or we could actually try and like make
him a better leader.
What,
what do you guys say it?
Think of that.
And then because hey,
we could try and get a replacement for him,
but at least he listens to us right now or whatever,
you know,
at least he,
at least he understands the job.
Hey,
let's try and let's try and prop them up.
Let's try and get,
we know what,
let's get rid of him,
but let's get rid of him by teaching him a lot.
So he gets educated so we can move on and get promoted and then we'll have a
good relationship with them.
Yeah.
And then the team will get more support and then we can do our mission better.
I guess he kind of didn't understand what makes them a quote unquote horrible
for sure.
For sure.
Like what if,
uh,
what if I don't like him cause I don't like his tie.
I Dunno.
I don't like his hair.
Do you know,
I just don't like him.
We don't,
we don't come from the same side of the tracks.
I don't know.
One of the things that would be like,
if the guy's arrogant,
the guy's arrogant,
well how are we going to bring him down?
How are we going to bring,
well,
how we not not bring him down,
like bring them down like from his job,
but how are we gonna bring down his ego?
How are we going to mellow him out?
You know?
And that could,
that could be a long project.
That could be a long project.
Yeah.
So just like how you said it,
like it,
is it damaging the,
the performance kind of thing?
Yes.
That's the most important thing is that what is our performance?
Like can we bring this guy around?
Good question.
I'm sorry.
There's no definitive answer,
but at the same time there's,
so leadership is,
is an art.
Yeah.
And why did the uh,
it's an art and science,
but it's an art,
Sir.
This is a case where the artistic part is going to be more important.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The dichotomy.
Alright.
Insight.
And when bloodsport how he called martial arts martial science,
he called
it more Marshall sites.
The Guy,
what is his name?
Since they Tanaka I come on Bro.
Bloodsport fend damp.
Yeah.
No,
I know.
I know what the movie is.
Yeah,
he called it Marshall.
I'm familiar with that.
Too familiar.
Even as a kid,
I thought those movies were really cheesy.
You can cheesy like show me like a lot,
a lot of MMA.
Well,
I guess from my age,
MMA guys,
you know,
I was into blood sport,
you know?
Yeah.
Even when I was a kid I w I wasn't thinking bloodsport was like legit.
I don't know why I thought it was one of the park yet.
The dim,
I thought rocky.
I thought rocky was more legit.
He's dope.
Yeah.
I thought,
I thought that rocky was a more legit than bloodsport for me.
Blood sports seem fake.
Yeah.
I guess it just seemed extreme,
I guess.
Cause Poe plus I think with bloodsport the rumors circulated,
the tech guy was real like,
don't you?
It's like you're like,
oh,
it's your sure it's a movie.
Cool.
It made it fun,
but it was real gonna lie.
I,
yeah.
Again,
I wouldn't say I hated bloodsport,
but like I haven't seen it enough to know that the guy referred to martial arts
as Marshall Science.
Those early on,
early in the movie when Van dam's teacher,
you know,
it's your typical movie,
right?
There's a,
there's a a guy and he's getting beat down or whatever.
He goes through his training process.
There's a,
there's a montage,
like in Timor team America,
world police,
there's a montage training montage and then he comes back and wins.
There's,
there's like most of your fight movies.
Yeah.
You know,
then montage he gets be done early.
he trains,
he becomes awesome.
But then there's the,
the arch enemy who's trained to,
yeah,
but still a bully and he has to beat him.
Same thing with credit kid.
But you're leaving out the montage part in a training montage,
which is very important.
You're the best or no,
that's credit kid.
You ever seen the movie never backed down?
No.
Okay,
so you wouldn't,
you'll never watched this movie.
It's,
it's,
it's MMA.
Right.
And I remember when it came out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it's basically Craddick kid.
It's literally like karate kid,
but just MMA now.
And little bit more cheesy.
Maybe a lot more cheesy.
I thought it was good though.
I enjoyed it and watch him like a master Jujitsu guy or something.
Yeah.
Brazilian guy who plays is played by an African guy.
The guy on your remember gladiator gladiator,
right?
Russell Crowe and even the black guy in there.
The African Guy?
Vaguely.
Yeah,
he um,
you know the one,
yeah,
the main friend.
Yeah,
he's the guy,
but he's a Brazilian guy.
It doesn't match because it doesn't Brazilian accent.
I was going to say houses,
Portuguese accent still African.
But nonetheless,
you know,
on paper it might seem cool,
but it came up kind of cheesy.
I liked it though.
You know,
they over emphasize like all the things like he goes to the party and the
party's just Chris' name anyway.
Yeah,
look into it nonetheless.
Yes.
Science and art.
I dig it.
You kind of have to,
I mean back to the question yet,
I have to kind of wonder why the boss is asking your opinion too.
Is it just a general probe?
Like,
hey,
how are you guys doing?
How's the Boston kind of like that?
Or is it,
well,
you have some concerns about your team leader.
What up,
you know,
kind of thing have,
even though you gotta be careful because they could lead you down that path.
Maybe.
Maybe they're probing you.
Yeah.
Maybe the team leader said,
hey,
you know what?
I don't trust this guy.
See what he says about me.
Right.
And then you go in and you go,
Hey,
I've heard some bad things about this guy.
What do you think of him?
Yeah.
Tell you what,
you're right.
That guy is a dirt.
Yeah.
Turd with ears.
You guys used to say that.
A lot of team,
they'd say Turd.
It's a team thing,
I think.
I think it came from buds.
At some point it was,
you'd get called turds quite a bit and then a person that was kind of maybe
just,
just not a very good individual would be a turn.
Yeah.
Years.
Never heard them.
In Hawaii they say do two boy,
same thing.
Do you do boy doodle boy.
Yeah,
but obviously not in any kind of discipline where you got one more,
one more question.
Yes.
Next question.
Last question.
Jocko.
I've been disciplined,
working hard and staying focused,
but I've hit a run of bad luck and I can't seem to get a break.
Well,
first of all,
you are lucky
because if you're capable of,
of working hard,
then that's a blessing.
That's luck.
Because there's people all over the world that don't have the ability for any
number of reasons.
Many of those reasons being just bad luck,
but they can't work.
So right out of the gate,
you're lucky that you can get up tomorrow and you can go to work.
Now you say you can't get a break
and maybe you're getting unlucky with your career or your personal life or your
business.
So
what are you going to do?
Are you going to give up?
Are you gonna Surrender?
Are you going to assume that because you didn't catch a break today?
There's no way you'll catch one tomorrow or next week or next year.
Are you going to leave it all to chance
or are you going to do everything in your power to force lock your way to create
opportunity to,
to shift the hands of fate.
And even then if the break never comes,
even if you roll across the finish line of life,
bruised and bloodied and empty handed from the fight,
at least you know,
you know
that you went after it as hard as you could.
Thank you.
Gave life everything you had
and you know in the end,
yeah,
you might still be unlucky.
That could happen,
but I would much rather be and unlucky soul.
Yeah,
that fought until the end and died with my sword in my hand.
Then an unlucky soul that's submitted,
bowed down,
gave up and surrendered.
So stop waiting to get lucky.
Stop waiting for a big break.
Instead,
be thankful,
truly thankful
for what you do have
and go out there and fight and battle and brawl to make your own luck
and I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So Echo.
Yes,
speaking of fighting hard.
Sure.
Is there anything you know about that can help us stay in the fight?
Stay in the foot,
continue fighting heart check.
Sure.
First thing you need to do need to do is take care of your body habitus.
You use that word wrong,
but body habitus is like your like your habitat on your body.
Anyway.
Take care of your body is when I met
including but not limited to your joints.
A lot more important than I thought from the beginning or at in the beginning,
so how you do that is Super Krill oil.
Jocko has super krill oil,
chocolates,
Krill oil called Super Krill oil,
another supplement called joint warfare.
These are good for your joints.
Don't neglect them.
That's how you see it in the fight.
Straight out.
Get them@originmain.com also,
you want to increase your capacity and capability in the fight physically,
mentally.
You take new product called discipline.
It's called
discipline.
It's not discipline itself.
It's called discipline.
Anyways,
cognitive and physical enhancer,
force multiplier,
mental plus physical.
The the sum is greater than the parts
anyway or didn't mean.com.
That's where you get them really good.
They also have ease in rash guards there at origin.
Me and they are all made in America.
I don't know if you know this,
it's a big deal.
He does good work over there from the dirt to this shirt.
Yeah.
Cotton.
It's even grown in America and that's very important.
Let's see what I did there.
Um,
yeah.
Keys,
rash guards,
compression gear,
pants,
compression pants,
spats all there also,
or just speaking of origin,
we have an immersion camp.
Jujitsu immersion camp.
All levels of Jujitsu are welcome to this by the way.
What about kids?
Kids will come to that one.
I don't think so.
Yeah.
Cause they have the capacity for kids there at camp shoot,
they're asking me that.
Interesting.
Nonetheless,
all levels,
even if you don't have any Jujitsu at all.
In fact,
last time there was a group who didn't have,
I think it was like some didn't have any duty,
have no juice and it just came and went on.
Like you know,
like some of the stuff you learn if you don't have any juice,
it's like,
okay,
that's not going to fit into my knowledge because you have no knowledge.
So it's like,
no,
that's not,
I don't understand this quite yet.
You like,
we did the like the fundamentals class form.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
And even during,
um,
like while it was going on,
I,
I had a group on the site of like a good,
like 12 people and we're just doing just the basic materials.
No dancer.
Yeah,
for sure.
All Levels.
And by the way,
if you're a beginner,
yeah,
that's cool.
But also if you're good,
you'll also get some awesome training there.
Yeah.
Everybody great guys.
They're huge.
Good.
Cool.
Yeah,
it's up in Maine.
Echo Lake.
Are we on the Echo Lake?
December on
Echo Lake layers.
Echo has got his own.
Make sure echo park,
Echo Lake.
Dang.
Nonetheless.
Yeah.
So yeah,
origin main.com you can look in,
see all that stuff and uh,
you know,
if you want something,
get something.
If you want to come to the emergency camp,
come to the immersion camp.
I'll be there.
Jacket.
You're going,
you're so mad.
Last time you couldn't do that.
Your Rib Rib,
rib was Jack and this year it won't be Jack.
No,
no,
no.
It's all good bro.
You're the man either way.
Also for fitness gear,
you want to vary up your workout.
You want to implement new movements?
Kettle bells.
Do you do kettle bells?
I know.
John,
can you do catapults?
I know that,
but that's the question.
Yeah,
you do Mike Grandchild,
right?
Mike,
this guy,
you know,
he's a brown belt or black belt.
I forget in Carlsbad area in who?
I have known him for a long time.
I used to work with a sister.
I don't even know if he remembers that,
but so watching you don't what you don't Jeff Clarkies.
Yeah.
So He's under him.
Um,
he hit me up.
He's like,
Hey,
I want to get into kettle bells.
No,
he's like,
I'm looking at the,
at ones or whatever.
You know,
asking the advice.
Here's the thing,
I'm not an expert on the kettle bells,
but I do know this.
Don't get nuts with them,
but don't go too light either though.
I bought a kettle bell for my daughter.
She's five now,
so it's just,
it looks cool.
It's like the one of the little,
no,
no man.
Anyway,
the smallest one,
but when I picked that up,
I'm like,
no matter what fitness level I'm at,
this isn't gonna do much for me,
so don't go too light is what I'm saying.
Yeah,
yeah.
Nonetheless.
Get them from on it.
Go on it.com/jocko some good stuff.
A lot of options there.
You think you're stuck in a boring movie Jocko workout super hard,
but but boring.
You're going to fall off that wagon.
Maybe.
I Dunno.
It depends on who you are,
but if you want a varied up,
go on at.com/chocolate gets them to do some good fitness gear.
Also,
when you're getting any of the books that we review on this podcast,
I got them organized for you on Jocko podcast.com click on the top books,
books section.
Think specifically it says books from Jocko podcasts.
Got Them organized by episode,
including Rob Jones Journeys Journal.
By the way,
pretty much anything that we're reading and we'll put it on there for access,
easy access and it happens to support,
takes you to Amazon.
Boom.
Get your book,
two day delivery,
one day delivery,
eight hour delivery sometimes and you know,
if you want to do other shopping,
continue on.
Do you be,
you also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already,
iTunes,
stitcher,
Google play,
uh,
a Spotify,
stitcher.
I already said to do true
everywhere.
Whatever you listen to podcasts on subscribe seems obvious,
right?
Also Youtube,
if you are interested in the video version of this podcast you want to see with
Jocko,
looks like if you care,
you'll see what I look like if you care,
which may be a little bit more of a thing because I apparently,
I don't sound how I look because still get that by the way.
Yeah,
no,
I just talked to a guy about the other day.
Yeah.
Yesterday.
That'll never go away.
Nope.
Until everyone has seen me.
No one sees me.
Anyway,
if you are interested in that youtube video version of this podcast,
also excerpts,
take little chunks out of the podcast and post them so you can share them so
they don't have to listen to two and a half,
three hours of a whole podcast to get one lesson,
one specific lesson that's not a youtube channel and you just made a new video.
I did.
Yeah.
I'm making more videos now.
Time is running out.
Those was an important one.
The,
you know,
so I'll
choose little excerpts or whatever to be like,
you know what,
this one to me hit harder.
This little message that you said and now one was because it is one of those
ones because you know how the,
the old saying where it's like,
yeah,
we know we had to have a limited time on this earth but we don't have clay kid
thing.
You know that whole thing.
And really when you think about that,
that's more true than I think most people realize.
And you know,
that's why people go through like midlife crisis,
right?
You know how they,
they hit a certain agent and get a corvette.
Yeah.
I gotta get,
I gotta get it back.
I don't know.
You know,
it's that scrambling situation.
you're trying to scramble to get,
get more in,
but you know there's gonna come a time you can't do that.
There's a little old school footage in there.
In that video.
Yeah.
To of if you want to see me when I was,
I don't know,
like 13 or 14 maybe.
Yeah.
I was probably 14 I'm going to guess 14 Bronson's children.
Bronson's children balance that Bronson staffing though.
Straight up it as you went through phases.
Right.
Somebody else decided to identify fully the actual,
cause.
We had a bunch of different names.
One of the names of the band was rage of discipline,
rage,
rage of discipline.
It will never disciples of discipline,
not something else,
just one.
It was rage of disciplined and it was,
it was struggle.
It was lock and load,
which is really militaristic for someone that wasn't in the military to be like
my band's called lock and load.
I realize how cheesy that is now.
It's pretty dope action.
No,
I don't know.
But anyways,
range of disciplines.
Real mill,
military ish.
See Bri,
you are you even before.
That's what the guy who got the video footage from Elgin James,
he,
when he comes on the podcast,
he's that guy.
I'm going to tell people I actually just a spoiler alert cause he's like,
I can't wait to tell everyone that you had a band called rage of discipline when
you were 14 years old and I was kind of laughing about that.
Yeah.
But you're in the making from the beginning.
I guess you could say that,
but you know also I also look back and think,
well man,
I did some dumb stuff when I was a kid.
Yeah.
Well you didn't get a handle on the discipline to later,
but the seed was there,
you know,
like a little rattlesnake.
You know how they say they're the most dangerous because they can't control the
venom.
They don't have the discipline.
Oh,
but didn't want the discipline.
That's what I think.
That's what I was like a little rattlesnake.
Yes.
Interestingly.
Right.
Nonetheless,
you can see these videos on youtube where the video is a cool video.
Yeah.
Thanks John.
Good Job Echo Charles.
Thanks.
I'm trying to do more videos.
Also,
Jack was a store,
it's called Jocko store.
This is where you can get discipline equals freedom shirts.
There's that word again.
Discipline,
you know,
iconic one.
Also rash guards on their women's stuff,
on their hoodies,
on their beanies.
Here's the thing,
the green beanies out a little bit more of a process,
but they've been approved and you know there's going to be some beanies on.
Their new shirt is out just in time for summer.
Good job.
Even though they're,
you know,
they'll need them down in Australia.
New Zealand.
Yeah.
It was summertime down there and the southern hemisphere.
In Hawaii News.
You're wearing a new shirt today.
Sorry.
Is this out back to the book?
It's out.
It's available because I didn't say anything.
I just kind of snuck it in there so some people got it live.
It's life or in life or a day.
The book back to the book.
It's actually good.
The front of it.
It has a book on the back,
has all the titles that you've reviewed or took it on anyway.
You wanna see what that looks like.
Jocko,
store.com if you want something,
get something.
It's a good way to support also psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is.
It's an album with tracks that each track is engineered.
It's not music tracks.
Jocko tracks engineered to help you through any moment of weakness that you may
stumble upon or that might stumble upon you.
Actually,
you shouldn't say stumble upon you,
cause that kind of gives the ownership to like,
oh it happens to me.
You know what I mean?
If you hit weakness,
you hit the weakness like you,
you stumbled on the weakness.
You can't blame the weakness.
He blame.
You see what I'm saying?
So you need moment of weakness that you happened to stumble upon.
There's a track for that procrastination.
Waking up early,
the Diet stuff,
falling off the diet wagon.
You want to eat some donuts cause they're free at work.
It's wasteful if you don't eat them.
It's disrespectful to the person who bought them
and you're,
you're,
you're going to eat them.
That's weak.
Stay on the path and if you need a little spot psychological warfare,
you can get it on Itunes,
Amazon music,
various where we can purchase mp3s,
bump,
get it from their psychological warfare.
It's a good one.
Good way to support to by the wicker where support.
Also,
if you need some more support,
you can get Jocko white tea and I've got some bad news and good news,
bad news.
They've started testing for Jocko white tea,
so they started testing.
They're worried,
you know,
they see guys just dominating and they're thinking they're probably on Jocko
white tea.
The good thing that's a bad news,
good news is it doesn't matter.
Can't test for it all natural.
It's all natural.
No one can believe that at fully natural substance can can raise any human
beings.
Dead lift to 8,000 pound minimum,
but there it is.
There it is.
Factual,
factual
books.
All right books.
You can get some books way the warrior kid.
This is the book for kids.
The book for kids.
See the feedback.
Go on,
go on social media,
go on Twitter,
go on Facebook,
you Baja and see
kids studying.
See kids doing pull ups,
see kids doing Jujitsu,
see kids getting after it.
That'll tell you right there.
So many parents have said,
I can't believe my kid now wants to study as they post little pictures of kids
making math flashcards.
That's what I'm talking about.
Imagine if you get your kid to do math flashcards voluntarily.
Boom.
So that's what I'm talking about.
And now there's a way the warrior kid to Mark's mission in this book,
Uncle Jake teaches young mark and he really teaches the rest of us how to
control his temper,
how to work hard,
how to be frugal and smart with money.
There's a little entrepreneurial activity in the book.
He also learns how to take care of his gear.
He learns how to save his money.
He learns how to deal with insults and with verbal abuse,
and he learns to overcome his fear of failure.
That's a lot to learn in one book.
Yeah,
but it's there.
What are the lessons are there and is done in a simple,
clear way that only uncle Jake knows how to do.
And speed of entrepreneurial warrior kids.
Don't forget about Aiden young Aiden,
he's only 12 years old,
but he has a business.
He's making soap from goat milk,
from goats on his form that he's not just making any soap,
he's making good soap.
He's making Jockos soap.
You can order it at Irish,
Irish oaks ranch.com and the motto,
which I thought of not given aid and any credit for this,
he didn't think of this motto.
I thought of the motto.
The motto is stay clean.
So yeah,
get yourself some Jocko soap.
You can also get a book called the discipline equals freedom field manual.
And that's another book.
The feedback is awesome.
If feedback is awesome,
people that get that book and they get on the path,
they get stronger,
healthier,
smarter,
more disciplined,
they're getting better and they live a better life.
And that's awesome to hear.
So if you or someone you know,
needs,
know how to get on the path and stay on the bath path than the field manual is
for them and it will help them do just that.
And for the audio version,
it's not on audible because then you can't have an album with tracks.
The audio version is on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
other MP three platforms.
So if you want the audio version,
get that.
Also,
obviously there's a book called extreme ownership.
It is combat leadership.
These are the lessons that we learned in combat,
translated into leadership principles for business and life.
And you know what?
It's still on the Amazon charts right now is number 17 on all Amazon charts for
books read or something like that.
So yeah,
you got to dig.
That does still selling and and and also announcement just went over a million
copies sold.
Yeah.
Which is pretty legit.
So thanks everyone for doing that,
for buying some books and copies of books.
And by the way,
you don't sell a million copies of books.
I have a book on just hype and we didn't do it through paid advertising,
which I don't even know if you could do it through paid advertising,
the book sales because the word of mouth.
So everyone that listens to this podcast buys the book,
spreads the word gets it for other people.
You're the reason that that book is selling so well still.
So thank you all for spreading the word,
telling people,
get it for them,
get it for their team,
up and down the chain of command.
Extreme ownership.
Pick it up.
Furthermore,
echelon front,
that's my leadership and management consulting company.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do.
And that is how all problems get solved through leadership.
So it's me,
it's Leif Babin,
it's JP Denelle.
It's Dave Burke.
You can email info@echelonfrontdotcomoryoucangotothewebsiteechelonfront.com and
of course we are approaching the muster.
This is the most dynamic leadership comp France ever of all time tickets are
selling.
Uh,
we,
we've already kind of expanded the floor in the location that we have in DC as
much as we can to accommodate more people.
But I'm telling you it's gonna sell out.
We're only doing two masters this year.
One is in Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th and one is in San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th.
So calm,
learn,
hang out,
get your pragmatic leadership skills.
And also it's important to know that there is no green room,
there's no backstage.
We'll be there hanging out,
answering questions,
talking,
eating,
working out and hanging out with everyone that shows up.
So join us there.
You can register@extremeownershipdotcomandalsoonextremeownership.com there's a
document that we put together.
So some people,
they want to come to the conference,
they need to run it up,
their chain of command,
and they kind of say,
well,
what should I say up my chain of command?
I want my chain of command them to pay for it,
which is awesome.
And the chain of command should pay for it because they're going to get back a,
a much better leader in their organization.
Uh,
but we put a document on there.
You can,
you can uh,
click on the link.
The,
the little,
what's that?
The little link,
I guess it's called a link.
It's called creating leaders at every level and that's also on extreme
ownership.com.
We'll see you there.
We'll see at the muster and until we do see you at the monster,
you can find us interacting and conversing and cruising,
cruising on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Dat food.
Dapo hockey echo is that Echo Charles and I am at jockowillink and thanks to
those of you out there in uniform around the world on foreign lands in the sky,
over our heads and on an under the high seas protecting us from the evil of the
world.
Thank you.
And thanks to police and law enforcement to the firefighters and paramedics and
all of you first responders.
Thanks for taking care of us and our families when we need it most.
And to everyone else out there,
the nurses and the doctors working all hours to heal us.
And the teacher's trying to educate our youth and the guys hanging dry wall and
pouring concrete and roughing in plumbing and electrical and the farmers growing
crops and the factory workers building products and the fishermen and the
lobstermen in the longshoreman and the bankers and the advisors and the
salespeople and the waitresses and the cooks and the dishwashers.
Okay.
To all the men and women across the land,
in every job,
in every capacity that show up every day.
Thanks for listening to us and thanks for doing your job and doing it well and
doing it with pride.
Okay.
And thanks for working hard to make your own luck and to make your part of the
world a better place,
okay.
By going out there and getting after it.
Okay.
And so until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.